deuxième journée du chasse.com 2022
global Championship salut Fab salut keV
salut à tous donc enfin bon c'était
quitté hier avec une première journée
palpitante avec des parties assez
extraordinaires et on espère que ça
continue sur le même rythme exactement
avec du suspense dans tous les matchs
donc voilà tout est encore possible
aujourd'hui donc on ne sait pas on verra
quoi alors on va regarder un peu comment
c'était quitté hier le match Sow André
kids ceux qui a déjà fait un petit écart
il mène trois un et il peut d'entrer de
jeu Fabien peut-être ben faire un écart
quasiment décisif trois points de retard
en trois parties ce serait trop pour
André Kim probablement normalement
on sait pas elle nous habitués quand
même des belles performances on sait pas
on verra on verra donc on attend le
début ça doit commencer à 17h alors
petit changement par rapport à hier
les parties commenceront à 17 heures
normalement 18h05 à 19h10 et 20h15 donc
il y a eu un petit il devrait y avoir un
léger décalage Fabien de de 5 minutes
pour pour laisser le le temps parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte hier comme
comme vous avez pu le voir vous aussi
que la la
l'entracte est un tout petit peu court
ouais non mais pas trop le temps de
faire des bonnes poses tu vois le temps
de descendre d'un étage de boire un café
de revenir ah merde faut déjà jouer donc
là au moins
d'ailleurs assez petite 5 minutes de
plus normalement qui qui vont permettre
de de bien souffler voilà il y aura pas
besoin de courir dans l'escalier donc
ils seront beaucoup plus
vous en forme beaucoup plus lucide ça
c'est rond et toucheront la souris
donc ça se lance la partie de Wesley est
pas encore lancée donc on attend pour le
moment le début de cette partie la
partie du carreau est lancée alors après
on a hésité avec Fabien avant on disait
est-ce que on suit quand même peut-être
une remontada de duda mais on n'y a pas
trop cru
bon on n'y croit pas trop mais après
bien sûr tout reste possible avoir un
petit bang cloud peut-être peut porter
ses fruits aujourd'hui on verra
qui est en train d'arriver
[Musique]
qui est en train d'arriver qui est là
voilà Issa assis
qui devrait s'asseoir aussi rapidement
je sais pas s'il a les blancs ou les
Noirs peut-être qu'il a les noirs pour
cette première partie en tout cas on
attend Fabien alors hier je crois qu'il
est fini avec les Noirs
[Musique]
je ne sais pas c'est pour ça c'est pour
ça donc
on attend on attend pour le moment André
Kin concentré Fabien qui
qui réfléchit là peut-être à son premier
coup on voyait peut-être un petit
décalage en fait ouais c'est la partie
du cargo qui débute en partie en partie
principale on aurait peut-être dû suivre
car où Fabien bon on peut aller voir
tu as besoin que d'une petite nulle pour
pour assurer la calife alors est-ce que
tu as eu le fameux est-ce qu'ils
joueront 8 parties quoi qu'il arrive ou
si on ne perd pas celle-là il sera
qualifié et normalement il sera qualifié
ouais d'après ce que j'ai compris il
sera qualifié et ça ira pas au bout
alors après
j'espère ne pas me tromper parce que
presque j'ai eu the match will be will
be finish mais alors est-ce que c'est
fini je dans le sens il aura gagné mais
on jouera quand même les parties où
est-ce que c'est fini dans le sens ça
s'arrête je suis pas allé
chercher vraiment le fin mot pour moi
c'est ça paraissait évident après on est
on n'est pas une
erreur d'interprétation près Fabien dans
ses règlements que
c'est vrai que souvent nous on voit les
choses un peu différemment tu vois on se
trompe souvent on se trompe souvent
aussi autre chose
après c'est voilà c'est la logique que
j'ai compris après c'est pas forcément
on a pu lire le premier 4 et demi gagne
ouais c'est ça mais après ça le rage
c'est ce que je disais ouais mais gagne
mais tu peux quand même continuer à
jouer même une fois que tu as gagné
voilà donc
il y a plus aucun intérêt mais tu peux
tu pourrais continuer à jouer donc moi
je l'ai compris comme toi mais après
voilà c'est toujours sujet à
interprétation donc je ne préfère pas
m'avancer de 3 alors que que l'autre
partie n'a toujours pas commencé Fabien
tu vois ils ont que eu jusqu'à 17h
aujourd'hui pour non alors que 5 minutes
de plus ça fait quand même plaisir quoi
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'il y a qui a
vraiment ce grand format sur e-caru qui
est qui est la partie principale et qui
veulent pas qu'elle s'arrête en même
temps que que les autres
donc voilà peut-être la la raison et
c'est vrai que
en nous on a décidé de pas assumer mais
le suspense quand même entier dans ce
match on a vu des remontades déjà je me
rappelle tu sais je crois que c'était un
Montpellier Marseille ou Marseille était
mené 4-0 à la mi-temps exactement
possibilité il y a aussi un match de
tennis je crois un mec qui était mené
6-050 et avait réussi à remonter la
table ouais ouais donc c'est tout est
toujours possible Fabien complètement
complètement d'ailleurs ils font bien
d'ailleurs de montrer que cette partie
de pas démarrer les autres
comme ça on sera bien sûr on verra et
imagine que Luda gagne faut-il qu'on ces
autres matchs et pas attendre 18 heures
pour la seconde ronde peut-être la
troisième la quatrième et commencer
peut-être ensuite à 21h la suite des
autres rencontres enfin ça peut être
intéressant aussi c'est
pourquoi pas
voilà est-ce que ça va se lancer 17h05
[Rires]
le marabout quoi bah oui donc
comme ça ouais je crois que c'est un
Roland où elle menait elle met un truc
comme ça
40 0 truc comme ça
ouais bon c'est une grande solide qui
joue
je crois qu'en gros tu prends pas
forcément le pion
avec les Blancs
et si tu le prends il y a toujours des
compensations mais après j'ai vu une que
saut il va te faire un truc pas trop
violent il va pas passer son temps à
manger des pions et être sous-développer
il va probablement
qu'il avait un peu jouer avec les Noirs
ouais ouais alors
je sais plus tard mais je crois qu'on
avait vu un poste
[Musique]
incroyable
donc ouais
mais
a priori oui donc c'est intéressant de
jouer pour les Noirs voilà je me
rappelle cet épisode a absolument
on avait regardé on était mort de rire
mais
qu'est-ce que je veux mais je crois que
en fait effectivement c'est plutôt une
bonne manière de parler
on va voir si il s'en sort bien
pour le moment on a la jauge qui donne
avantage blanc mais faut faire attention
à cette jauge Fabien ouais c'est une
jette quoi elle permet un peu de jauger
la situation mais objectivement on peut
pas forcément suivre les yeux fermés
cette turbinette par rapport à d'autres
turbines plus puissantes et en fait
évidemment ben lui il est content parce
qu'il voit qu'il a un pion de plus et de
toute façon les ordinateurs ont toujours
tendance à adorer le matériel
après faut dire que ben voilà on est mal
développé
et qui aura toujours des compensations
en face et que c'est pas si simple à
jouer en réel
surtout que sauve assurer nul là
ouais bon disons s'il y gagne fini
attention il y aura que 3 points d'écart
quand même hein 3 points d'écart 3
parties attention Fabien quand même il
faut il faut raisons garder il faut
raison garder le suspense restera quand
même entier mais il fera un un petit pas
vers la victoire on va dire ça comme ça
mais défaite 3-2 ici il est quasiment
plus favori quoi ah non c'est très chaud
pourquoi pas parce que c'est grand rock
l'idée ou simplement une tour en D8 on
va voir
un logiquement tu as envie de faire
fouger 5 et qui va les dessins non
après faut j'ai 5 H 6 problèmes de pieds
des cinq c'est peut-être des des
ou après
l'ordi n'est pas du tout content et ne
crois pas Échec
cavalier G4 peut-être la sœur
on se rendra pas les combines après 3 et
on se développe
[Musique]
j'en sais rien mais
c'est vrai que tu connais pas trop avec
les Blancs tu peux dire ouais c'est
peut-être dangereux ça a l'air d'être un
excellent choix pour pardon il est mené
il a raison de prendre sa chance
parce que ton suit pas mais bon oui il
fait forcément il a il a une remontade à
faire aujourd'hui à tout moment il peut
la faire
là il va il va il va tenter de mettre
des premières parties avec les Noirs
après gagner encore avec les blancs puis
regagner avec les Noirs tout est
possible ça reste le match le match
principal une partie puis une autre
ça peut à tout moment à tout moment
tourner c'est vite arrivé à aux échecs
super une partie tu perds un peu
confiance et la mer j'avais perdu la
tempera une deuxième la troisième jamais
203 et tu te retrouves dans une partie
décisive Fabien à 4-3
bah ouais ouais puis là tu te dis il
faut pas que
faut pas que je fasse le con c'est bon
père une quatrième et tu es en
Armageddon tu sais pas pourquoi voilà
peu de chance que ça se passe bien parce
que mentalement tu es touché voilà et tu
perds le match et dans deux coups de
cuillère à pot là bam bam bam bam
peut-être une stratégie de Douda au
final
dans cette dans cette situation
pour se dire voilà si je fais tourner le
match retour
une stratégie donc dans cette quatrième
partie éventuellement
intéressant Fabien ça c'est tout
l'expérience qui parle mais du coup
naquai s'il doit d'autant plus être au
courant ah bah voilà et donc du coup
peut-être c'est ouais ce sera peut-être
l'arroseur arroser va peut-être perdre 4
et demi en demi en fait
ma ca va peut-être se dire au contraire
faut que je reste sur mes gardes c'est
des stratégies voilà
et tu as qui remonte il remonte pas
après bon ça se passerait c'est quand
même souvent comme ça c'est une
stratégie quand même un petit peu risqué
c'est mené 4-0 pour viser le 5 4 ça
marche pas tous les jours non plus
ça peut de façon entendre mais moi je
l'ai jamais vu après
non mais on ne sait pas ouais c'est ça
non mais après voilà c'est toujours ça
on sait jamais en fait
il fait 3 ouais bah ça a l'air dans ce
match aussi de vite de vite se décanter
parce que là
il est mal développé mais il fait ce
qu'il peut il a sorti son foodcas noir
avant de l'emmer il veut sortir le foie
fin il veut ok enfin il fait que des
trucs normaux bah c'est vrai que s'il y
a pas
une petite tactique un petit truc rapide
avec les noirs
pardon bah un moment tu auras juste un
pion de moins pour pas grand chose mais
là bon tu as encore mieux développer on
va voir
mais faut trouver quelque chose dans les
quoi venir ça se passe pas trop mal pour
le moment pour pour Wesley ce match
après moi quel match alors si celui-là
se décanter je serai plutôt pour suivre
guérir à jabov ou séviant Sarine
de rêve derrière ouais peut-être c'est
bien Sarine des joueurs qu'on a moins
l'habitude de voir mais bon c'est pas
obligatoire
Wesley qui enlève ou là il enlève ses
lunettes il enlève tout là ou attention
quand même j'espère qu'il y a les
arbitres pas loin
j'ai pas pourquoi ils sont obligés de
mettre un casque en fait
ils sont obligés
peut-être parce qu'il y a du bruit
autour mais
je sais pas c'est dérangeant pour moi
c'est dérangeant jouer avec un casque
bon moi j'en ai sur les oreilles ça va
je suis bien mais
[Musique]
un peu par exemple non mais en soit oui
je vois pas pourquoi on sera obligé de
l'avoir quoi
c'est pas fini les cars ils étaient pas
bien sûr alors non ça se joue sur deux
jours je le répète du coup pour ceux qui
l'ont dit à plusieurs reprises hier mais
ça se joue sur sur deux jours c'est en 8
parties les matchs attention Cyril voilà
c'est en huit parties sera huit parties
des cars 8 parties les demi et attention
pour la finale Fabien attention
je ne dis pas assez je dis directement
là pour ceux qui sont là la finale se
joue sur dimanche et lundi intuitivement
pourrait pourrait avoir l'impression que
que la finale est dimanche mais mais le
le dénouement final sera lundi attention
non mais c'est quand même le jour idoine
pour finir une finale comme d'habitude
les échecs ont bien compris
dimanche dimanche donc on aura quatre
parties et lundi on aura quatre autres
parties
grand classique grand classique bravo on
se démarque quand même d'autres sports
qui n'ont pas l'intelligence de finir un
indice quoi
c'est très contre-intuitif moi aussi
j'avais noté dans mon calendrier j'avais
vu du 2 au 7 je t'ai dit à 20h c'est du
mercredi au dimanche et je m'étais je
m'étais je m'étais fait piéger donc je
le je le signale
[Musique]
complètement du coup on prend un jour de
congé lundi pour terminer le tournoi
exactement comme ça vous pouvez dès à
présent poser votre lundi pour pouvoir
suivre la finale qui à mon avis opposera
Nakamura à
quand même qui sera qui sera très
qualitative
ouais et donc dimanche soir pour nous en
France mais lundi pardon soit pour nous
en France la finale mais sur le lieu du
tournoi à Toronto ça se terminera un
lundi mais en milieu d'après-midi
très bien comme ça tu as bien le temps
de faire l'armée des frites quand même
le plus important non c'est à la remise
des prix ou pas mais
en tout cas Fabien ça se terminera donc
lundi en milieu d'après-midi du côté du
Canada et de la jolie ville de Toronto
sans rigoler notre rôle je pense que
c'est réellement le la difficulté qu'il
y a eu et du coup ça décalé là la date
d'un jour
complexe quand même dommage de jouer un
jour férié ça c'est vrai peut-être la
salle n'était pas libre ou les
va savoir va savoir Fabien je suis pas
au courant de
de ce côté là
donc il a dit il a fait trois bon bah on
va on va attendre le prochain coup
après voilà ce qui est dommage pour
Android
que je sais pas à quel point c'est bon
pas bon quoi mais c'est dommage qu'il
soit pas plus au courant en fait imagine
tu joues ça tu connais bien ça peut être
dangereux après si tu joues ça et quand
tu es livré à toi-même Paso il peut
il peut défendre
je veux dire si tu joues les coups que
tu as toute analysé avec l'ordi tu es
bien quoi
si tu joues humainement tu as juste un
pion de moi tu as pas de raison
d'arriver à forcément à autre playlist
après d'un autre côté André King c'est à
dire qu'il a quoi ici match perdu en
vrai
ce que tu as un accueil il a dit j'ai vu
un interview qu'il était content qu'il y
avait réussi à caler deux trois petites
prépa donc j'imagine qu'il parlait
surtout de la partie 1 ou la vite mis
dedans danger dans la pétrole oui ouais
complètement et puis même dans sa
berlinoise ça c'est intéressant là sont
son truc enfin intéressant ou pas
d'ailleurs mais il avait un peu moins là
puis les foutu reposer les gagner très
vite donc je suppose que les joueurs
enfin il y a quand même plus d'argent
que pour les championnats du monde enfin
c'est il y a plus d'argent qu'au
candidats aussi mis à part pas la
première place donc faut dire que les
joueurs peuvent vraiment sortir des
prépas là c'est un des tournois les
c'est peut-être même le tournoi le mieux
doté de l'année parce qu'il y a plus
d'argent que dans les grandes chaises
tours aussi
c'est toujours plus que les candidats
donc
partant de là
c'est pas étonnant en quelque sorte que
les joueurs soient bien préparés
c'est vrai que tu as pas envie de
prendre le tournoi par dessus la jambe
non plus à ce moment-là donc
pourquoi je disais dans ce cas-là que
oui peut-être mener 3-1
ouais pour plus il s'en fout quand même
il veut pas remettre de préparation j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas ça se voit
qu'il a pas l'air face à pas l'air fou
fou quoi ce qu'il est en train de faire
non enfin bon on va voir on sait jamais
non mais on sait pas mais je leur parle
là ça a pas l'air non non mais je suis
d'accord c'est pas le truc qu'on se dit
ouais j'ai bien de leur jouer moi ça me
l'a intéressant ça casse pas trois
pattes à un canard quoi
oui en fait je m'étais super bien
préparé j'avais je m'étais vraiment fait
un gros fichier et du coup je
connaissais plein de trucs par coeur et
c'est vrai que quand tu joues par cœur
c'est dangereux voilà mais c'est comme
ça
exactement
c'est mais en soi c'est un peu la même
idée quoi et quand tu connais bien c'est
dangereux
mais bon c'était livré à toi même
là-dedans ça va pas trop bien se passer
après si tu connais pas tout bien les
pièges et tout
bah ouais depuis tu as besoin de jouer
vite comme tu dis puis quand tu joues
vite ça fait aussi un peu peur à
l'adversaire on va pas se mentir
donc je vais vite ça permet
enfin voilà
tout est possible à toute façon c'est un
pion de plus
et c'est un gros avantage au blanc
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu veux y faire
mais après le problème c'est que nul ça
t'arrange vraiment pas et que
pas trop enfin bon tu es pas tu tires
pas mort avec nul mais
c'est vrai que avant la partie du signe
pas pour ça
on va voir il y a plus qu'à attendre
pour savoir alors je pense que si le
match de Naka Douda finit avant les
parties recommencera un peu plus tôt je
sais pas comment ça va se passer
je crois qu'après ça débarrasse 5 à 10
je sais pas j'avais vu ça dépend du
match de Naka ça peut
parce qu'en fait c'est ça en fait il
démarre une partie et les autres en
décalé en fait
pourquoi pas
après si ça décale d'une minute ou deux
bon après je sais pas ça te permet de
voir le coup d'envoi quoi
la première avec les autres
et c'est la première c'est celle qui
juge le plus intéressantes
la variante des fous des deux fous
bourrés
aucune idée de comment s'appelle ça va
rien hein
je pense pas
fait voir en fait chez skamid donne les
noms mais comment je peux voir ça
bon bien à zéro et jouer 4
je pense pas que ça s'appelle comme ça
référence à une vidéo du chat c'est pas
le nom en fait c'est juste un clic sur
une vidéo en fait
aucun rapport en fait ouais fausse
alerte
ça s'appelle pas du tout comme ça
c'est pas possible
donc
j'ai cinq fougères
j'avais étudié plein de trucs
je t'ai fait un fichier
j'aurais réalisé comme Becky ah bah oui
j'avais été gagnant contre André King
quand même en title avec nul je crois
bah ouais mais tu vois
oui peut-être qu'il s'est dit ça
ressemble vraiment
mais j'ai des bons résultats contre lui
c'est Baki qui suit
tu peux même te dire les résultats que
j'ai contre lui c'est écrit là j'ai pas
un très beau j'ai pas un si mauvais
score attends
je vais te dire
j'ai une victoire de nul qui a de
défaite
une partie qui a perdu contre moi
26 octobre tu as joué tu as perdu
mais je suis dégoûté je l'ai joué hier
soir
il a accepté une partie mais je
discutais avec le chat j'ai pas regardé
l'échiquier je t'ai complètement gagnant
et
mais j'ai joué sans regarder l'échiquier
en fait ça qui est beau
j'étais quand même gagnant fait et j'ai
gaffé au 30 ou 35e
c'est pas très bien passé pour lui
aussi ils ont commencé à bouffer en
dessin qui a joué la finale
il envoie la pièce bon on voit la jauge
hein que ça marche pas du tout là il y a
pas trop à hésité juste tu regardes la
jauge et que tu as l'évaluation mais du
coup ça doit juste être plus en prendre
à me prendre enfin et tout enfin il y a
rien en fait
mais parce que ce pleutre sur G4 il veut
d'un F4 je pense
et faire la finale qui est complètement
nulle
c'est magnifique en fait oui
il veut juste nul ouais
déjà faut voir jauge malheureusement non
mais ce serait une sacrée aide et là il
veut d'un F4 c'est sûr qu'est-ce qu'il
est pleutre quand même
on peut rappeler qu'est-ce que les
enjeux du tournoi oui on peut te le
rappeler bah c'est il y a c'est le
tournoi le mieux doté de l'année je
crois celui qui a le plus d'argent
donc voilà l'enjeu l'argent donc tous
ces jours là sont qualifiés par internet
et maintenant ça joue en réel et on a ce
qui était pas les hier quelques quelques
aficionados experts du jeu sur Internet
comme Raja BOV Sarine André King un
petit peu saut aussi
qui sont vraiment des experts
du jeu internet
ikaro aussi bien évidemment
et de joueurs qu'on voit plus
ponctuellement
comme diri séviens enseignant qui
n'était pas qualifié qui a été repêché
mais oui parce que les vannes n'a pas pu
venir jouer il n'y a qu'un objectif
d'argent ah ouais là c'est le seul
objectif ça joue tu pourras mettre sur
ton palmarès j'ai gagné
[Musique]
comme beaucoup ont un échecs les saisons
sont très mal construites il y a peu de
tournois vraiment prestigieux en fait
c'est surtout tous les tournois du cycle
pour le Championnat du Monde le reste ça
joue quand même globalement que pour
l'argent
Magnus n'a pas réussi à se qualifier en
Magnus n'a pas n'a pas joué les Cali
tout comme à l'IRESA dans les joueurs
connus ce qui n'ont pas essayé et dans
les joueurs vraiment forts qui sont
faits éliminer il y a des pomyachi qui
se fait sortir un parabab comme je le
disais on peut bien chic très en forme
mais bon voilà contre un spécialiste il
a il a un petit peu souffert et digne
aussi d'ingly Rennes donc les limites
les deux finalistes championnats du
monde et éliminés par Niall Sarine lui
aussi qui s'est vraiment le jeune Indien
spécialisé sur sur les joutes internet
dernièrement un peu comme pragalanda ces
jeunes Indiens qui sont vraiment très
faibles
des champions tours
les Indiens qui sont vraiment qui se
spécialisent aussi petit à petit après
c'est là où il y a le plus d'argent je
les comprends aussi assez logique de
plus se spécialiser
et Maxime Maxime il est perdu contre ses
viandes avec commenté le match en direct
mais il avait joué il avait pas
joué peut-être non je crois qu'il s'est
fait éliminer aussi Fabiano alors je
sais plus par qui quelqu'un pourra me
dire j'avais vu tout le tableau mais tu
vois je me rappelle de quasiment tout le
monde mais car Wana ça m'échappe
bon ça change ça change
plus sur le jeu en réel au final
comme Maxime
c'est intéressant quand même
la transition c'est le sol et Magnus en
Magnus remarque plutôt sur sur les
tomates qui leur gagnent mais
en soit comme on disait hier c'est pas
idiot pour un joueur professionnel
Fabien de se spécialiser vraiment sur
Internet parce qu'au final si tu si tu
additionnes les titles Tuesday les trucs
les machins les champions il y a
réellement plus d'argent sur le circuit
internet que sur le circuit réel
ouais surtout il y a plein de tournois
tout le temps alors après bon tu faisais
normalement tu vas pas faire fortune
avec tu fais juste un peu de Bernard
épinards mais c'est quoi
je crois que tu peux faire 1000 sur
chaque mardi enfin tu vois si tu peux
faire 4000 par mois
qui a une très très souvent il fait
quand même pas 100 % non ouais enfin tu
peux facilement faire dans les 800000
dollars par mois tu as les arènes
actings tu en as qui refont de l'argent
tu as assez tournant là tu avais le truc
du weekend où tu avais 10000 dollars
tous les week-ends
tu peux vite faire 400 500000 euros par
an donc c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça
que la spécialisation les joueurs qui se
spécialise sur Internet au final il y a
réellement plus d'argent
après ouais
il y a eu ça il y a aussi la calife au
960 ou même si tu arrives après en réel
et tu finissais alors on va pas dire
dernier parce qu'il y avait le joueur
islandais mais je crois que tu arrivais
vite à 450000 dollars tu as eu aussi les
tournois du Grand chaise sur la quand
c'était sur internet tu avais peut-être
aussi un petit 100000 quand même au
premier jour c'est ouais genre c'était
si tu fais une grosse saison alors qu'en
réel au final tu as quoi tu as les
grandes chaises sourdes tu vois tu fais
quand même pas grand chose mais non plus
c'est dur d'y aller les jouer c'est
quand chez toi exactement alors que là
c'est fermé
ouais on dit ouais guéri aussi on le
voit de moins en moins réel de plus en
plus sur internet non mais cette
spécialisation elle est elle est pas
elle est pas sans faire sens
financièrement ça fait du sens en réel
tu peux peut-être plus facilement de
sponsor ben non les joueurs n'ont pas de
sponsor généralement
c'est moins difficile qu'une signature
alors attention continue parce que le
niveau des parties pendant discuter avec
d'autres joueurs pro quand tu regardes
le niveau sur Internet les spécialistes
d'Internet jouent vraiment très très
bien il faut pas penser qu'il joue moins
bien que parfois même mieux parfois même
mieux non non c'est c'est un jeu un
petit peu différent les échiquiers de
D3D etc et état des joueurs bah qui sont
qui sont devenus spécialistes de la
discipline et qui ont eux aussi un
niveau assez important
non tu as été médisant complètement
le niveau des parties est loin d'être
ridicule
il y a j'ose pas aussi qui s'est
spécialisé bortnik aussi il y en avait
eu d'autres à avant eux qui étaient
vraiment spécialiste et qui était
reconnu pour être plus fort sur internet
quand en temps réel
bah changer les tours
la plupart des gens au niveau similaire
sur les deux mais voilà tu as prêtes à
les spécialistes de de l'écran d'Ed
peut-être une meilleure acuité visuelle
et qui réussissent à mieux à mieux jouer
et qui a eu des six si l'attaque B7 il
menace qui est assez huit qui est prend
à 7 attention
quand il a plus aucun risque de perdre
si tu lui fais un petit cadeau il va
aller la chercher voilà je pense qu'il
va la gagner ouais
[Musique]
le classique pour défendre réattaquer
entre les pions
des fois c'est hallucinant
et Douda qui a gagné
la stratégie en marche
des parties non mais vous avez
réellement des joueurs qui sont
nettement plus forts sur Internet enfin
je veux dire c'est un fait c'est pas la
peine de
enfin je comprends que vous questionnez
mais non enfin tu as des joueurs qui
sont ouais ils sont plus habiles à la
souris
et ça fait une différence et il s'en
sortent mieux sur Internet qu'en réel
pas la pression dans l'adversaire en
face de toi aussi
moins de tension exactement l'idée t'as
pas le voyage pour aller au tournoi
ouais il y a plein de petits facteurs
qui s'additionnent et qui font que les
joueurs
jouent mieux sur Internet enfin c'est
très bien quand en ligne
exactement
et voilà tu es bien
ouais et il y a une victoire de guéri
ok qui s'envole un peu ouais
et demi maintenant ouais bah vu la
solidité des deux
ça va être quoi dire rideau mais ça
c'est incroyable quand il est le truc
quand même
[Musique]
après ça a gagné facile non
ça se trouve c'est ordinateur
généralement
moi récemment mais
je me souviens quand il est à givra le
tard qu'il y avait justement le truc
pour les battements de cœur il battait
du cœur comme un fouet
et puis tu pousses enfin c'est hyper
facile mais il avait même il saigné du
nez des fois qu'on est parti
bon là il va pouvoir le gérer plus
tranquillement
on a quand même pas choisi une partie
magnifique comme ça
peut-être c'est pas le coup à jouer
alors attends cette partie je peux
essayer de récupérer les cames parce que
je pense que c'est le match qu'on va
regarder après puisque ce sera peut-être
le dernier match serré parce que les
autres matchs
je crois qu'ils ont un problème de Cam
on va voir
ok donc c'est Vian il a les blancs
oui
je vais récupérer
voilà
qui pourrait piquer quasiment le match
sur la séviant je pense c'est le match
qu'on suivra ça va être le moins les
trois autres en fait ils sont quasi
pliés en réalité
en tous les cas et c'est peut-être celui
il y a le plus de chances que ça tourne
quoi
vous avez changé
c'est magnifique au moins on voit
mais tu vois ta soon qui je suis
tiraillé entre regarder Djoko catchana
où se tourna l'exceptionnel complexe
plutôt
quand même bah tu regrettes pas d'avoir
raté si mon frites pour avoir vu hier
nakadua sound attention
il faudrait pas tu vois t'as pas fait
l'erreur hier ne l'a fait pas
aujourd'hui voilà c'est ça
on n'a même pas besoin de VOUS du coup
si on a la barre je sais pas dans quel
sens comprendre cette phrase Ludo
moi il y a peut-être des jeux de mots là
qui se perdent attention Ludo tension
il est peut-être pas bien en fait c'est
bien
[Musique]
non ils sont pas chez eux non ça se voit
en fait qu'ils sont pas chez eux
avec son roi un peu dans les courants
d'air mais bon peut-être qu'il veut pas
qu'il va faire autre chose mais moi je
sauterai sur dame
française quand même
l'avantage avec séviance c'est que si la
soif on sait ce qu'il boit
de quoi de l'avion
[Rires]
pas logique c'est logique
pourquoi ils sont pas en face les deux
alors là ce qu'il y en a qui sont Serbie
et d'autres qui sont à Toronto
ça coule de source
et donc ce qui est bien c'est que ça
permettra d'avoir une pause un petit peu
plus longue Fabien puisque les parties
reprendront donc à
18h05-19h10 et 20h15
j'en profiter pour soigner cette toux
qui est venu de nulle part je sais pas
pourquoi
c'est le covid de 17h quoi enfin juste
avant ça tout allait très bien j'ai
envie de mon petit match de tennis j'ai
pris ma douche tout je suis là et puis
tu as gagné ouais alors j'ai gagné j'ai
bien gagné d'ailleurs c'est 06 0
j'avais vu en fait roi des deux dames
mais c'est marrant parce que je lui ai
pas dit mais j'allais dire faire gaffe
de pas faire [ __ ] parce que ça perd en
ligne oui bah c'est la ligne en fait non
c'est que fallait sauter sur la Chanchan
compliquée comme ça surtout quand tu
mets nos scores et que là tu te voilà
tu veux une plus rien du tout
bonne position c'est bien il est
complètement dominé et puis là d'un coup
ça tourne toi
[Musique]
mais ça fait du bien ça la première fois
que je gagne un match quoi
[Musique]
c'est heureux quoi et donc
lundi j'ai le deuxième match de la poule
et si je vienne je passe le tour sinon
bah je passe rien du tout et puis voilà
mais on verra donc j'essaierai d'être
sur pied moi je vais devoir me remettre
là pour qu'on fasse notre notre tournoi
mais
[Musique]
du coup je sers un peu mieux je suis un
peu mieux de trucs qu'avant mais bon là
ça commence c'est le début on verra mais
non
je joue pas bien je sers pas bien
mon gros défaut pour l'instant c'est
physique quoi aux adducteurs j'ai mal
partout aujourd'hui j'ai hyper peur en
fait de pas être capable de trouver mais
ça va comme je te dis mais comme il m'a
pas fait courir j'ai pu bien masquer
quoi juste tapé dans la valse
on verra lundi
donc tu es prêt déjà pour ton deuxième
tour et tu joues combien tu joues encore
un 30 34
je pense c'est jouable mais bon faut que
je puisse tenir debout correctement
tu devrais pouvoir ben je suis combien
là je suis 35 mais comme je dis j'ai
fait je fais que 3 matchs dans ma vie
quoi en fait donc c'est le classement il
peut pas les super vite faut marquer un
peu les puntos
don de défaite bon de défaite
aussi non des mecs à 15 15 5 15 4 donc 2
x 15 je sais plus d'ailleurs
massacré ou pas complètement dernière
fois je vais faire du 6 4 6 2 ça va en
fait mais peut-être plus fort enfin je
veux dire
j'aurais tu vois enfin je regrettais
parce que le service n'était pas ça
enfin genre le match où je persiste 4 6
le mec ça va le briquet 4 fois et je
prends je fais que deux services en tout
et tu vois c'est con de jamais conserver
trop son service quoi d'être tout le
temps en difficulté c'est chiant
mais ça c'était mon regret mais je viens
même si c'était un peu mieux le service
je sentais que dans le jeu j'étais
plutôt en difficulté là pour le coup
c'est moi qui avait pas trop à mettre en
danger je courais partout je devais que
défendre et
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu enfin tu vois
j'aurais tu vois le premier 7 ouais ben
le problème c'est qu'il y a 5 4 pour lui
je sers je me refais briquer comme d'hab
mais tu vois je pouvais un peu accrocher
mais c'était plus l'accrocher le
plombant aussi peut-être choper un 7
mais c'était pas c'était pas mieux
mais bon
c'est pas un niveau qui me semble
accessible si je progresse
déjà le service
physique et puis un peu un peu plus de
régularité mais bon ça faut jouer il
faut voilà
donc on verra la semaine dernière
j'avais fait un stage j'avais été mise
tous les jours une heure et demie
mais c'est peut-être là que je me suis
un peu défoncé physiquement parce que là
j'ai tenté de rejouer mardi et justement
pour très vite j'avais mal partout et
j'étais hyper inquiet pour aujourd'hui
du coup comme je te dis mais bon là ça
va j'ai pas trop transpiré c'est bon
mes services cuillères bah je fais pas
non en fait je fais pas double faute
mais c'est juste que c'est trop
inoffensif ce que je fais déjà le mec
qui joue pas mal il m'attaque direct
c'est même pas que j'arrive à faire une
mise en jeu où on fait un échange c'est
en fait je me fais allumer et bon je
fais ce que je peux que je galope mais
bon
les services cuillère si tu le maîtrises
bien normalement tu es pas censé de
faire attaquer non bah bien bien
truc c'est que je sais pas le faire
enfin j'ai jamais essayé de le faire
correctement
là le truc pour le service au moins on a
fait une séance la semaine dernière donc
c'est un peu mieux déjà
bon après c'est pas encore bien c'est
juste un peu mieux
le problème c'est la première balle la
deuxième ou c'est tout
ma première j'essaie déjà de faire une
deuxième pour pas faire double faute
mais ça ça va si j'en fais une par match
ou deux bon tu vois c'est pas non plus
mais
bon si je fais un service ou c'est un
engagement de compte comme ça quand la
taper donc là il m'a appris un peu à
essayer de faire du kick le service pour
que ça rebondit c'est tu vas me faire
pas me faire allumer direct
donc surtout côté avantage j'essaye de
faire ça sur le revers du gars pour un
peu le pas me prendre une mine
c'est chaud
et ok bon moi ça ça va donc
voilà il y a ça à mettre en place on
verra petit à petit
tu joues moins bien que Mazet encore
[Musique]
je pense j'aurais jamais mieux que lui
parce que
je joue déjà juste bien dans le jeu il a
il tape bien et physiquement il est très
bien tu vois
donc il y a pas match enfin
si je conduis tu peux arracher quelques
jeux par-ci par là mais mais maxi pour
l'instant enfin et comme je te dis même
en blague je fais un peu plus de tennis
qu'avant
pas le truc c'est que lui aussi quoi
c'est pas que s'il lui a agressait donc
avec des lois enfin et là il est il est
5 6 maisons c'est beaucoup de placement
devant déjà le jour où je passe 15
quelque chose je serai ce sera déjà beau
mais il y a encore un écran d'écart qui
est énorme quoi ouais donc tu es très
lent mais Amazon tu penses qu'il peut
faire réussir à être zéro
non c'est trop long Mazo je sais pas
s'il y en a encore un ou deux classement
c'est magnifique mais ça m'a l'air dur
de faire beaucoup plus que ce qu'il a
fait là
après on sait jamais parce que
tel était dernier là que tu joues à
Cannes il a quasiment passé de Tours
peut-être pas du tout cette année quand
il va aller refaire il a pas de points à
défendre peut-être il va aller choper un
petit classement un truc
mais ouais il a 5 6 ouais c'est beau
enfin c'est vraiment un très très bon
niveau 5 6
à 0 tu as encore c'est encore loin quoi
je sais pas trop quel leur met mais
mais
il joue bien c'est vrai il joue bien et
joue souvent il est propre dans son jeu
et comme je dis en plus physiquement il
tient bien le coup le match peut durer
il se déplace bien il a de l'endurance
donc
et toi ton objectif du coup c'est 15
objectifs
à quelle vitesse bouge les classements
donc en fait
là comme cette année je fais je vais
faire quelques matchs interclub ici ou
là le championnat de la Loire du coup
c'est ce que je joue là on va voir si je
passe un tour ou deux ou pas tu as
peut-être lundi aussi bon et puis bah je
verrai à quelle vitesse ça bouge ou quoi
puis je verrai ce qu'il faut que je
fasse pour avancer et je pourrai plus te
dire après là je joue pour jouer je sais
pas apparemment tu veux juste gagner un
7 puis un autre voilà c'est ça bah là en
fait tu vois c'est la première fois que
je gagnais un match parce que sur le
troisième que je fais j'en ai fait un
autre qui compte pour le classement mais
c'est un peu des trucs à la con c'est
toujours contre quelqu'un que tu connais
tant que tu es mal classé en dessous de
30 tu peux le compter pour ton
classement c'est pas une chose échecs
t'invite un pote chez toi tu tiens vas-y
on fait une partie longue et ça compte
pour le vélo tant de témoin de 1200 ou
je sais pas en fait fin
mais tu vois enfin c'est pas la même
condition donc là je vais gagner mais
c'était pas voilà donc en fait j'ai fait
j'avais fait deux vrai match de défaite
et là c'est le troisième vrai match
c'est la première fois que je gagne donc
bah suivant comment ça bouge je te dirai
quoi
donc en double on va on va être en sueur
quoi parce que moi je suis
catastrophique j'ai pas du tout le temps
de jouer quoi c'est terrible pas écoute
en double déjà on galope à moi
on fera un peu de voler un peu de
service et puis et puis ça va quoi on
met les barbares après me débarbbles
faudra juste ce qu'on comprenne deux
trois automatismes c'est des trucs
où faut des fois tourner genre en fait
si tu es au filet ou je suis au filet je
me fais lober donc ce mec de derrière
d'aller prendre la balle mais du coup
faut pas rester comme un plot là faut
inverser pour reprendre l'autre l'autre
côté mais en fait ça tu as jamais joué
en double tabou le savoir de l'avoir vu
la télé en fait tu es dessus tu es un
peu comme un con sur le terrain à
regarder ce qui se passe donc de le
faire naturellement déjà tu vois on sera
bien quoi enfin si on fait deux trois
matchs amicaux machin bon on fera ce
qu'on peut et puis on perd on perce pas
là ah bah moi j'ai envie de gagner quand
même passer un tour quoi c'est dur
mais je pense faudrait qu'on se fasse
des sessions faudra qu'on prenne
on fait un peu de la volé quand même
pour être mais je pense que si on a si
je réussis un peu à fixer le service que
toi tu sers bien on sert et après on met
des barbeulles on sert l'envoi des
plombs et ils font des retours à la con
les smatch et c'est fini allez hop on
passe un tour on arrête on rentre chez
nous ça dégage la racaille on publie un
vlogue ah bah ouais bah on peut faire un
après on pourrait lancer un retour
Roland Garros avec Mazet
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
alors les amis on est deux on est de
retour
qui doit revenir
incessamment sous peu
c'est quoi son nom c'est un énorme un
énorme tournoi
c'est un énorme tournoi sur internet
avec 200000 euros de prix donc là on est
on est sur du très lourd il y a fab qui
est de retour qui se faisait une petite
pause mais oui ouais je suis de retour
pas forcément le tiempo Fab quand même
non mais là ça va pendant 5 minutes non
ouais je crois je crois on va voir
un petit truc chaud
pour la gorge voilà
on va attendre que ça reprenne qu'est-ce
que tu veux lui faire d'autre
on va suivre ce match Sarine c'est bien
ouais donc du coup dans les autres
matchs ça y a déjà des grosses
différences
saumon de 3 points
et c'est le match qui est serré celui
entre sévillian et Sarine donc où il y a
encore égalité
c'est bien qui devait pas être là
profite du forfait de Levan
ouais après écoute bon petit jeu c'est
bien
sûr c'est pas un joueur de l'élite mais
bon il va défendre ses chances on
verraine serrée hier il a bien dominé
quand même
c'est pas bien payé pour lui d'être
égalité après 5 parties on va dire
sur le contenu
c'est le deuxième jour les matchs jouent
sur deux jours c'est quand même
c'est mieux moi je trouve que c'est bien
ce format Fabien de jouer de jouer sur
deux jours
ah bah écoute oui pas pourquoi pas enfin
ça te permet que c'était pas en forme un
jour
tu peux tu peux peut-être te refaire un
peu la cerise la nuit et le lendemain
être là exactement
c'est une idée assez intéressante
donc ouais donc c'est des matchs en 8
parties et c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
une bonne chose
on espère revoir ces idées peut-être les
speechs aussi les faire tu vois pour le
moment c'est ça joue sur une journée
3h30
tu attends le lendemain tu refais une
autre heure et demi non non faire le
double c'est-à-dire faire 3 jours non
non non non non tu vas pas compris c'est
en fait faire le même format mais x 2 ah
oui d'accord donc 3h30 et 3h30 le
lendemain ouais un peu
peut-être une troisième journée alors
non avant
mais ce serait pas mal en fait parce que
ça permettrait tu vois il y a quand même
eu des matchs où tu avais des joueurs
qui étaient menés de 7 8 9 points étudie
est-ce que
s'il y avait une une deuxième journée de
de compétition peut-être un peu tu vois
rentrer différemment dans le match et
tout il pourrait il pourrait revenir et
ça donnerait plus de de possibilités
pour pour travailler le match
peut-être la première journée il est là
à prendre le style adverse et le
lendemain il adapte sa stratégie c'est
ça il se reprend il revient plus fort et
c'est vrai que tu peux penser regarde le
match par exemple la caméra ouifane
il y avait eu je crois il y avait 24 à 1
est-ce que le deuxième jour aurait
changé la dynamique
alors après bon dur d'imaginer un
retournement complet de situation mais
peut-être un match plus serré
on attend en tout cas j'avais pas bien
compris donc c'est 18h05 le début ouais
de
Naka et 18h10 voir même 18h15 seulement
le début de notre partition on est
revenu un petit peu trop tôt
c'est pas grave on est là maintenant
bonsoir pour des prochaines donc ce soir
peut-être que on en a jusqu'à 21h et
quelques
décalage quand même assez intéressant
qu'il a aussi une là c'est une nouveauté
au fil de l'eau qu'ils ont qui a été
décidé
ah ben il s'adapte pour rendre le suivi
plus passionnant ouais exactement
l'adaptation qui est là
et donc on va on va attendre donc qui a
commencé normalement les autres parties
mais peut-être que ça rine c'est bien
c'est complètement décalé en fait
alors que ce week-end il y aura le rugby
en même temps donc on pourra bien
profiter des poses Fabien
ouais c'est pas mal ça
[Musique]
j'espère que ça commencera le truc c'est
que tu as à 16h15 tu as le tu as payé de
Galles Nouvelle-Zélande donc la mi-temps
devrait être à 17 heures
donc on espère vite vite les parties
et oui
donc ça tombera on sera bien content de
les avoir ces poses femmes
après j'espère que
je suis quand même un très beau maître
Saint-Étienne à regarder à 21h
[Musique]
tu le rattraperas pas forcément parce
que si la partie se finit à 21h et qui a
peut-être une demi-heure trois quart
d'heure de pause avant l'Armageddon ah
c'est pas mal
la deuxième mi-temps de match de rugby
sont-elles jouées le lundi alors non et
les testsmatch là sont joués samedi et
dimanche dimanche tu auras Angleterre
Argentine je crois non il joue le
week-end le rugby qui joue généralement
les samedis et dimanches les les gros
matchs il y aura aussi samedi matin
[Musique]
un petit donc samedi le soir là où ce
soit toujours un petit
Nouvelle-Zélande
France demi-finale de Coupe du monde de
rugby féminin que je vous recommande
chaudement samedi matin à 7h30 ici il y
aura le réveil pour suivre les joueuses
françaises j'en avais parlé ouais qui
sera probablement un beau match n'a
jamais regardé de rugby féminin c'est
peut-être l'occasion de regarder un
match qui sera sympathique Fabien je te
conseille de mettre ton réveil ouais
mais je regarderai ça peut être ça peut
être très sympa ça peut être très très
sympa je pense que les Françaises ont
une carte à jouer elles ont des bons
résultats généralement contre les
néo-zélandaises
c'est une équipe qui l'a réussi bien
on joue à ce française bon après elles
sont à domicile les néo-zélandaises donc
ce sera difficile mais bon elles ont
peut-être une carte à jouer et elle
retrouveront en finale le vainqueur du
match Canada Angleterre ouais avec les
anglaises qui sont évidemment grandes
favorites de la compétition qui nous
avait battu très à 7 en groupe et les
Canadiennes ça joue pas mal ouais ça
joue pas mal d'accord ça existe pas au
rugby mais un petit peu en fait ok c'est
pas il y a des bons joueurs canadiens au
rugby ils sont bon rugby à 7 enfin bon
ils ont une bonne équipe et c'est dans
les pays d'Amérique du Nord États-Unis
Canada bon c'est pas des grandes équipes
mais il y a ça joue un petit peu quand
même les Etats-Unis ils arrivent pas
trois semaines il pourrait presque donc
je sais pas tu te dis de voir des beaux
bébés des mecs qui font un peu du
football américain qui pourrait ils ont
été bon à 7 notamment avec un avec un
jeu qui s'appelle
Terry Baker un Élie assez extraordinaire
mais ils ont jamais
réussi vraiment à 15 à faire une grosse
équipe ils avaient aussi un joueur qui
joue à Biarritz si tu te rappelles qui
s'appelait d'une guenia qui était un
biarro je crois qu'il jouait 14 et qui
était un ailier assez incroyable une
pointe de vitesse incroyable
je crois qu'il pourrait se remettre en
moins de 10 secondes ou en 10 secondes
05 ouais c'était bon en gros si tu lui
mettais un bon ballon sur l'aile tu le
revoyais plus et Becker leurs joueurs à
7 avait un petit peu ce style là oui
c'était un un joueur qui était vraiment
dans l'évitement Péry Baker ouais
exactement comme un de chaque côté
à 7 ils ont une très grosse équipe les
États-Unis dans un moment ils avaient
ils avaient deux joueurs aussi qui
aurait été probablement centre ou
troisième ligne au rugby normal je me
rappelle plus les noms peut-être il et
un autre qui était ils ont ils ont une
très une très très grosse équipe à 7 qui
rivalise avec les meilleurs là ils sont
un peu un peu en dessous en ce moment
mais États-Unis Canada ça joue pas si
mal en réalité
qui avait collé une bronchite à Habana
exactement dans un match Biarritz Toulon
si je me rappelle bien
Ryan Habana
box
alors est-ce que ça va reprendre sa
reprise du côté de saut nous on attend
encore notre partie ouais nous en fait
on reprend des Calais
nous on reprend des cadeaux
[Musique]
on peut mettre un petit peu d'y carreaux
en attendant
on va voir on va avoir le match se plier
et imagine imagine qu'il perd dans le
corps
complexe
pourquoi ça reprend décalé ouais c'est
en décalé maintenant Théodore c'est
mieux comme ça ça permet vraiment de
voir tous les matchs
matchs du Sud du sa ouais alors j'ai pas
j'ai pas la ref
qui regarde le rugby féminin ici de
temps en temps qui a déjà vu un match
moi j'en ai pas vu beaucoup j'ai vu 4 5
matchs
qui regarde un tout petit peu
mal de l'équipe de France évidemment
non elles sont vraiment fortes les
Français sont vraiment fortes
c'est quoi
ouais non franchement tu seras tu seras
agréablement surpris
puis en demi-finale de Coupe du Monde on
a en Nouvelle-Zélande c'est beau quand
même c'est beau ce qu'elles font les
joueuses
ça joue très bien
tu vois un petit peu un petit peu comme
moi tu as suivi l'équipe de France et
tout le monde tu vois te confirme on a
une très grosse équipe
on y en féminin je regarde que la box
car elles sont plus techniques que les
hommes
voici il y a plein de sport en fait où
elles sont assez techniques
tennis par contre je trouve que ça joue
quand même moins bien
moins d'effet je trouve
là c'est un peu plus en cloche ou très
mais
on n'a aucune chance hein
mais non mais je veux dire
je sais pas enfin j'ai vu j'étais un peu
relance cette année et
j'ai bien match d'Alizée cornet donc je
sais plus une chose pas génial avec bien
gagner le match
mais déjà rien qu'à l'échauffement sans
voyait quoi enfin
pour chauffer l'épaule c'est et tu dis
ouais en fait tu as pas cet effet à la
télé quoi c'est tu vois comme ça tape
c'est
des joueurs c'est encore autre chose
parce que dans la foulée j'avais pu voir
le match le dernier match de contre rude
et donc oui on voit des missiles mais
mec déjà le premier match tu vois
Alizée l'échauffement et déjà
ça rigole pas quoi
tu vois en plus c'est pas là
6 0 6 0 que des ail s'il prendrait non
je pense qu'il retournerait un peu pas
que des ice
bah normalement les amis le fort quoi
mais de toute façon quand tu vois les
matchs les doubles mixtes
tu vois qu'elle renvoie même même tu
mets j'avais vu fait derrière dans un
double BX qui joue en diagonale contre
une fille mais c'était un match quoi
enfin genre c'était pas il lui donnait
pas des balles pour qu'elle tape en fait
elle renvoyait enfin il y avait aucun
problème elle renvoyait les balles de
Rogers dans la diagonale c'était pas
attention mais elles ont un peu moins de
changement d'effet je gère par la Corée
de vie tu verras qu'elles sont assez
techniques en fait
il est 4-6 ouais il est 4 6 7 il
prendrait pas 6 0 6 0 en fait je sais
pas vraiment
exactement ce que ça veut dire
[Musique]
mais bon Cathy c'est moins 4 6
il nous écrit ça joue euh
4 6 bah c'est fort mais c'est pas pareil
c'est pas négatif quoi
son oncle avait un très bon niveau il
était soit 30e 60e joueur français bon
dans les deux cas enfin 30e c'est
vraiment très très fort mais sans
trentième déjà tu es excellent
pas un point
mazoïc croyait mais Gaëlle ça le faisait
marrer
et oui en a eu sous quoi égal il était
mort de rire
[Rires]
j'imagine que pour Gaëlle c'est
maso quand il sert c'est nous des
participes pédagogiques en fait
si je sers hyper fort
ça accroche la ligne extérieure que
c'est vrai que sur un miracle je sais
pas quoi tu te dis
déjà je pense qu'on retourne il retourne
pas une balle de Gaëlle non
[Musique]
pas le problème c'est que même alléchant
enfin tu vois pas comment tu marques un
point juste n'importe quelle situation
[Musique]
bah oui
complètement
ouais après une balelette c'est la seule
chance en fait oui voilà
un miracle en fait
c'est la seule chance tu peux pas
autrement
et il veut pas commencer un jour
c'est déjà 18h17 quoi
c'est complètement en décalé maintenant
c'est pour que ça joue bien tout le
temps en fait
non mais en plus on a vraiment pas de
chance de suivre ce match là qui va
commencer le dernier quoi ouais
de pause à chaque fois tous
Fab il est pas bien Fabien
c'est terrible
Favier pas bien ouais c'est vrai que
c'est
ouais et puis tu
[Musique]
je suis fou quoi c'est tout je regarde
là je suis supporter donc voilà je
regarderai tableau tout le monde
national je regarderai toujours enfin
c'est comme ça il y a pas d'explication
au travail mais en soit je conseille
personne de regarder les matchs pour
voir du beau foot enfin genre hier comme
je disais moi j'arrête un peu la Ligue
des Champions Salzburg c'était sympa
franchement
doublé de Giroud passe décisive il était
bon
politique de prendre des jeunes de les
faire grandir après ils m'ont dit vendre
tout le temps donc ils ont des jeunes à
bon potentiel
qui s'ajoute pas ça c'est agréable quoi
comme match
mais voilà du coup tu vois enfin ça je
peux regarder etc et pourquoi pas synthé
c'est je regarde vraiment pour
l'explication quoi c'est juste du
supporterisme de base quoi c'est
complètement con en fait ouais ouais
[Musique]
ouais bah c'est même pas du plaisir de
faire je sais pas ce que je regarde je
suis là je suis ah j'étais complètement
fou quand tu regardes c'est terrible
mais ça va j'ai eu de la chance de
supporters Federer quoi au moins bon
je peux supporter Nick un gars qui
gagnait pas toujours mais ok mais c'est
vrai que supporter tout le temps c'est
dur quoi c'est mais c'est comme ça quoi
j'ai envie de dire enfin c'est mais
peut-être avoir un peu de Coupe de la
Ligue là non ah non non rien du tout il
y a plus supprimer et la Coupe de France
on a perdu quand même au premier tour
donc non non j'aurais que de la Ligue 2
pour se maintenir éventuellement ah le
cahier
c'est pas que
l'idée c'est que sur dessin il veut
faire eux prendre c'est prendre 5 échecs
échanger petit rock et ça a l'air de
rien mais tu vas faire B3 fou B2 genre
full 7 on va dire bloquer la colonne B3
rock B2
et tu te dis que tu es un peu meilleure
structure c'est vrai tu as deux îlots
contre 3 tu peux potentiellement
peut-être faire un petit C4 avant et
c'est d'échanger ses comptes et
d'essayer les pions isolés en face
tu as un fou pas mal placé sur la
diagonale voilà donc c'est pas grand
chose mais c'est pas rien non plus
donc une à jouer avec trois ok donc
c'est 5 en fait c'est je connais pas
mais c'est une autre manière de jouer il
a fait qu'il y avait trois attaque le
fou et a priori la turbinette n'aime pas
trop parce qu'il dit qu'il y avait des
problèmes 4 mais si tu connais pas
faux-et parce que tu te mets un peu avec
les pièces en l'air à droite à gauche et
puis même s'il y a rien de trop tactique
qui est prend C5 pour prendre la paire
de fou et jouer
un pion de moi mais bon c'est un peu
ouvert je sais pas ce que ça va enfin
stoppez super dangereux pour le noir
mais c'est pas c'est pas anodin non plus
comme position enfin si tu connais bien
que les blancs il a l'air parce qu'il
joue tempo ça fait un peu peur ok
d'ailleurs il a pas pris
ouais ben c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
le jeu contre quelqu'un qui connaît très
bien toi tu sais viens il est un peu en
danger là
quelque chose comme ça ouais ça
ressemble une nièce mais si c'est
possible
de l'autre côté mais là il prend la
caisse du cavalier et puis tu as deux
fous de fou qui font rien donc je sais
pas vrai ça peut mal se passer pour pour
les Noirs attraper dans l'ouverture un
petit peu là on va voir si la solution
du problème ou pas mais c'est pas
évident
jouer
a
pas super envie
qu'on a une bonne version de la mienne
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'il a envie de faire au
prochain coup
dangereux
toujours été une ouverture dangereuse
évidemment avec les ordinateurs ils ont
réussi à fermer toutes les lignes mais
en soi quand tu connais pas tu peux
perdre en vaincre
oui non non mais
en fait c'est cavalier surtout qu'ils
ont traité le truc
et des 5 enfin
tenir des trucs très compliqués il faut
bien connaître assez loin mais à priori
ça tient ça ça marche mais toutes les
autres elles sont jamais trop claires et
là donc il y a eu des deux bah le
problème c'est que ça va marquer deux
trois puntos au début puis ça va être
fermé très vite aussi
ah bah oui ça va être fermé c'est sûr
donc là faut en profiter tranquille
encore temps
[Musique]
un territoire un peu un peu inexploré
mais ouais mauvaise nouvelle ça va pas
durer c'est dommage parce que ça donne
des positions intéressantes en plus à
jouer c'est un peu différent de 4,5
habituels là c'est peut-être toi je
crois tourger 3 déjà
ou tu trois fous 3 parfois pour échanger
revenir avec la tour en E3
après tu peux jouer avec des G3 Fougères
c'est dommage que en fait cette
ouverture là elle se fait souvent fermée
c'est le problème de
toutes les ouvertures
et d'où 960 souvent
c'est
ouais c'est un vrai problème
toutes les ouvertures se font juste
fermées
on va voir comment ça a l'air
intéressant
c'est très typique comme coup dans ces
milesis en fait tu as plein de coups
typiques de lanésie qui sont des coups
complètement inhabituels oui oui du coup
c'est dur à jouer comme par comme
variante
bah disons que si tu en joules souvent
tu as quand même un avantage sur
l'adversaire parce que c'est pas c'est
pas des coûts communs
mais ça rime il est peut-être pas giga
expérimenté non plus dans l'ouverture
malheureusement
c'était fou G5 mais il empêche un couple
et sur H6 tu fais tour H3 ouais bah
c'est le H4 l'eau de manière générale
c'est ça
et en fait l'idée sur H6 c'est que tu
dis oui mais ça a servi quasiment à rien
mais en fait ça te sert à sortir ta tour
vers E3 donc là tu peux caler avec vous
trois sur metator en E3 et après tu as
le choix avec ton roi en fait elle est
hyper bien placée cette tour en trois
globalement
c'est encore assez large
[Musique]
ils a fond l'italienne l'espagnol mais
après il allait en espagnol mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que l'espagnol genre
quand tu vois la berlinoise il se trouve
cassé les dents maintenant ils essayent
des trucs un peu symétriques enfin c'est
pas loin d'être semi fermé quoi juste
comme chaque fois tu essayes un petit
truc un peu différent
tu essayes un peu mais c'est pas en
balant quand tu te prends les Marshalls
tu vois des potes tu lui demandes son
avis il va te dire ah ouais bon c'est
peut-être pas fermé mais c'est pas loin
enfin quand ça il a pas grand-chose quoi
et
et donc bon il veut taper sur le kib3
c'est bien joué mais du coup tu auras je
crois c'est vraiment enfin c'est
vraiment un coup multifonction j'avais
pas vu
après tu te mets un peu on vis-à-vis du
oui mais bon tu vas te décaler en G3 tu
te mets en face
parce que le truc en fait c'est que sur
genre froid des 6 tour G3 admettons il y
a pas d'impro E5 enfin il y a peut-être
remarque pas parce qu'on a pas tout
droit
d'habitude il est de l'autre côté
[Musique]
je sais pas comment on va faire ça
mais tu as trop d'activités tu vas avoir
toutes les pièces en jeu tu vas être
bien ouais tu vas peut-être faire un
petit
si je pouvais
genre même [ __ ]
enfin je sais pas le coup que j'ai envie
de faire [ __ ] de base mais ce qui est
ici tellement moche j'aurai pas envie de
le voir revenir en C5 mais casser les
pieds quoi après toi aussi dame 4 fous
des trois très rapide pour aller taper
le rock sur petit
menacerait pas vraiment cavaliers
j'y crois pas en fait j'ai l'impression
que c'est complètement foutu pour les
Noirs déjà mais bon
la jauge donne égal je réfléchirai déjà
un coup comme cavalier C5 avec les Noirs
perso
même si
après on prend fout prendre un G4
j'achète
qui tient
je sais pas vraiment un cavalier 5 mais
la turbine va détester à cause de
cavalier prendre à me prendre ou prends
les pousser trois directs
[Musique]
du tout en fait pour
le roi tu en avance 1000 fois en avance
pour moi tu as deux doigts de perdre un
mec avec les noirs
ouverture aide
non mais vraiment
mais on a senti assez vite on va pousser
cinq qui est B3
écoute tu vois cette deuxième journée
riche en surprise comme quoi il faut
mieux que ça joue sur deux jours que sur
un mais bon après est-ce que il faudrait
mieux pas que ça joue sur 4 jours
ben oui
[Musique]
tellement gros que le tournoi pourrait
bien durer
deux trois semaines moi je pense ça
serait pas mal quoi
bah ce serait pas délirant en réalité
vous plaisir de voir ça chaque jour
trois semaines un mois
mais finalement les candidats ça dure
bien trois semaines
et B3 donc il y aura un débat ce serait
ce serait intéressant quoi
en fait on pourrait faire quatre jours
le quart de finale
on met deux jours de pause après 6 jours
la demi
3 jours 3 jours de pause et la finale
découpée en deux fois quatre fois deux
quatre jours enfin deux jours en jours
de pause deux jours deux jours de pause
deux jours un jour de pause un jour un
jour de pause et jour final
peut-être du coup tu pourras le faire
moitié en Serbie moitié au Canada ok
ouais tu feras un changement
du coup faudra se remettre dans le
décalage peut-être trois quatre jours
pose encore pour
pour bien bien souffler dans le bon dans
le monde jetlag quoi mais voilà
l'écran d'ailleurs aussi Théodore il y a
un cheesecum global Championship aller
chercher ouais on pourrait du coup on
ferait ça ferait quoi ça ferait 4 jours
ça ferait bon en fait si tu fais 4 jours
le quart de finale en fait en vrai je
pense que deux jours un jour de pause 2
jours
tu finis ton quart tu fais deux jours de
pause entre les deux
tu fais la moitié de la demi-finale
après tu fais 5 jours de pause au milieu
pour que les joueurs puissent se
déplacer alors peut-être je suis un
autre stop en Europe à un moment donné
peut-être tu fais Serbie tu vas jusqu'à
Londres
et après tu repars simplement
d'ailleurs
le lit spot ça peut être très heureux
d'accueillir une phase
complètement
après on pourrait faire six parties par
jour
ouais alors après attention si par jour
peut-être qu'il y a un peu trop de
fatigue on sera un peu moins sûr
peut-être deux parties par jour on
garderait quatre parties et mais c'est
vrai qu'il y aurait moyen de vu que le
pricepool est important il y aurait le
moyen vraiment de faire un tournoi où tu
on pourrait même aller jusqu'à Vega soit
comme dit Théodore on pourrait terminer
la finale à Vegas exactement il y a
peut-être un créneau à prendre
bah oui tu fais ça
pour finir c'est pas mal quoi
non non il y a peut-être un truc à faire
oh
c'est la première saison tu imagines un
peu comme ça peut être grandiose par la
suite quoi
et pourquoi pas le retour de la journée
et pourquoi pas
mais ce fric dans ce temps et pourquoi
bah cette chaise comme là qui qui
finance ce tournoi qui est une belle
invention que à sa première saison je
pense que ça va que ça va revenir
est-ce que le format sera le même ou pas
comme on le disait il y a peut-être il y
a peut-être des idées à voir
[Musique]
exactement enfin rapide donc c'est pas
des
oui bon oui ça compte pour la cadence
mais du coup on pourrait penser un
circuit peut-être qui se met en place ou
tu pourrais même faire des parties de
lentes comme ça hybride ou des Blitz que
tu veux quoi
c'est classé fille rapide
en ligne et dernier rang en IRL c'est
plutôt chouette je trouve c'est une très
bonne idée ça permet comme on en parlait
plutôt aux spécialistes du jeu internet
de justement d'avoir des des résultats
aussi donc ça ça favorise un petit peu
le tout toutes les toutes les pratiques
du jeu donc très clairement
très clairement c'est une excellente
idée c'est calife sur internet ça avait
été pris au championnat du monde 960 ça
a été refait pour pour ce gros tournoi
et pourquoi pas même un jour voir des
candidats sur Internet enfin
vivre avec son temps ouais
ça pourrait être ça pourrait être une
idée
donc là ouais c'est sympa tu as toute
cette phase et là on va voir la preuve
classique nous aussi on jouera à partir
de février
qui se joue sur Internet jusqu'en
demi-finale bon on va essayer d'avoir
une belle équipe après on sait jamais
qualifié et mais c'est vrai qu'après on
était tombé sur sur des bureaux sur des
gros morceaux on avait on avait perdu
contre l'équipe norvégienne quand même
qui était grosse équipe qui moi m'avait
fait qui m'avait fait très mal après les
joueurs étaient des spécialistes aussi
donc je me suis fait un peu spécialifié
l'équipe de de Marseille de Maxime qui
avait perdu contre l'équipe slovène qui
avait un joueur à 21 50 là qui était
assez extraordinaire très très faible
aussi ce qui est devenu celui-là
il a joué que la première saison après
aussi ouais dans les équipes de génie
l'équipe arménienne aussi
si on réussiras mais il faudra là aussi
qu'on se bouge un peu et qu'on ait un
qu'on réussisse
pourquoi pas regarder quoi bonjour à
on prend des 6
on rentre dans une phase de jeu
différent on dira pas d'attaque trop
contre les rois parce qu'il y a des
dames échangées mais meilleure structure
pour les blancs
mais on peut pas gagner le pion des 6
parce qu'il y a F2 en prise
peut-être même un coup de fouine comme
ça qui nous fait une double attaque
[Musique]
et on arrive pas à récupérer
la tourelle le full ou le cavalier bien
vu Fab ah mes tours c'est 7 peut-être un
coup de fouine comme fou
e56
bon tu es pas trop bien mais tu gigotes
quoi
au lieu de gigoter tu essayes carrément
d'avoir un vrai avantage et qu'il y a 5
attaque C6 attaque des six
c'est pas mal il est il met la pression
avec les blancs en tout cas
je vois bien gagner cette partie quand
même avec les Blancs
aujourd'hui ça se passe beaucoup mieux
pour lui il est en souffrance à chaque
fois blanc noir mais bon il y a quand
même bien mis les barbelés comme ça les
mâles voilà c'est surtout l'ouverture en
fait qui
mais d'où l'important en fait de pas
complètement prendre l'eau qu'on ne t'es
pas bien
et ça peut ça peut jouer
alors que Wesley saut a remporté le
match un 4,5
c'est terminé côté Wesley
ça doit ça doit être quasi fait
quoique
on rigole depuis tout à l'heure mais en
fait il est pas bien
non enfin en fait
mais il va il va y retourner la tourne
et puis il va créer un pion passé
t'attaque un peu ce serait un peu
tellement bien fait pour lui qui perdent
non mais bon il va pas perdre les quatre
en fait non mais pour Douda ce serait
très bien fait pour lui qui perdent
trois et demi à quatre et demi et qui
paye son son
oui oui non mais c'est assez grave
au lieu de perdre ça ferait déjà 3 3 le
match il est pas si alors après ça
change tu joues pas pareil
si c'est possible j'en sais rien
peut-être parce que là avant tu fais
quand même bloqué il veut que c'est 5
secondes donc il va pas arriver mais oui
en tout cas clairement pas même ton bon
club tu aurais fait nul déjà une partie
normale de perdre comme ça de jeter à la
poubelle la partie
[Musique]
donc là on regarde si tu fais là tu as
pas perdu en fait
après il doit être dégoûté de cette
arnaquer comme il s'est fait arnaquer
mais bon après oui mais
ça peut arriver à
je sais pas le chemin du monde de blés
de jouer l'an dernier il a fait il est
fini en finale et des partages j'imagine
que dans le tournoi ce qui aime faire
arnaquer une fois deux pendant le Pen
enfin pendant il a pas jeté à la
poubelle un bon club après à pas jouer
non mais en plus ce que je veux dire
c'est vraiment dommage parce que si tu
as envie de jouer un truc un peu
exotique et te refaire plaisir parce que
tu as mais je sais pas on va même un
combi roi une vie noire un grand bidule
centre quand bioco enfin un truc un peu
ok c'est pas grave enfin
donc là c'est bien il a gagné donc ça ça
me tient un peu de suspense mais
là en fait c'est juste cracher sur les
échecs
en plus c'est bien fait pour lui quand
même
il savait que ça comptait pour le wow
après c'est rapide en personne on a rien
à faire Théodore
mais marrant tu vois il y a encore eu un
truc non pas du tennis et les autres
sports qui font genre
plus ou moins sanctionné moodet ah bah
oui bah ils ont eu raison ouais mais
c'est sorti hier tu vois pendant parlait
dans les autres
écarts de conduite on va dire de
comportement pas génial sur le cours et
du coup sanction est-ce qu'on voit
jamais quoi en fait il peut faire ce que
tu veux c'est pour ça que je dis souvent
est-ce que tu pisser sur l'adversaire
réellement au premier degré à la fin des
parties pour voir juste pour essayer
dans le respect bien sûr juste pour voir
je sais pas si tu arrives à quelque
chose en fait
si tu as un œil mais aussi
je sais pas si tu si t'es réellement
sanctionné ou pas il devrait essayer en
fait vu qu'il est en plein titre là
depuis plusieurs mois il devrait se
lâcher puis tu vois la réaction un peu
quoi tu auras des gens dire oui il a
bien fait sûrement
on n'est pas la caméra des joueurs de la
partie bah on l'a là
ça a une séance et les caméras à gauche
c'était juste la partie du carreau le
temps de changer les caméras la partie
elle est terminée donc
on n'a pas de régie ici il faut à la
fois commenter cliquer etc donc là
c'était juste pour pour faire un petit
tour des stades rapidos mais c'est
plutôt ce match là qu'on suit mais bon
peut-être retournera voir
Ikao par la suite
si jamais ça commence à complètement se
retourner
c'est incroyable
il peut vraiment s'en vouloir d'avoir
tellement troll Douda en réalité il joue
pas moins bien qu'il carreau mais juste
ouais pas assez vite et il a trop fait
n'importe quoi dans
dans ces parties avec les Blancs hier
la première tu vois il a peur il était
bien
c'était la Catalane là qu'on avait vu en
direct
dedans il s'est griffé merde mais voilà
par contre l'autre
c'est dommage ça aurait pu faire un vrai
match
ça reste encore plus haut bah ça serait
magnifique mais on avait annoncé au
début Fab que ça
avait parlé de la stratégie on vous
avait dit Carlos c'est pas fait avoir et
tu vois d'Andre King qui a été moins
fourbe
très pleutre de la partie il a pas
appris par dessus la jambe et bon ben
pleut très éclairé qui a marqué les
points qui revient à 3,5
donc c'est la dernière partie là
bon on va voir si c'est bien arrive à
tenir hier Sarine lui a sauvé des trucs
encore pire que ça notamment celle où la
main
et c'était fini en tout cas
donc on va voir on va voir si
c'est bien arrive à s'accrocher pareil
mais le réalisme important quand tu es
bien dans ces matchs c'est important de
scorer ce qui n'a pas assez fait hier il
a peut-être pas un crasso non non
au fond Fab ah bah oui chirurgicale ah
c'est plus du pintor exactement
qui peut semer
le fou bah ouais mais le cavalier est
bloqué aussi en fait et le fou il va
repartir un jour
ouais ouais le fou c'est mieux en fait
il a plus de Bruxelles que le cavalier
par le cavalier il faudra arriver à
faire marcher un qui est ici 5 par
miracle puis on prend bien mais bon
[Musique]
j'avoue
toi aussi bah du coup ouais enfin du
coup je me dis ouais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait sur un truc sur le cavalier machin
puis bah oui en fait il y a juste le
foie
cyber qui nous demande si c'est pas moi
de bloquer le fou par principe t'as pas
envie de te bloquer un fou là déjà il
est bloqué dans le bon sens parce qu'il
est devant les pions même si on aide et
quelque part aussi il est très chiant
aussi bloque les caméras racistes qu'on
peut attaquer et le jour où il s'en va
de façon d'autrefois 5 il va ressortir
tu vois tu ramènes une autre tour tu
peux aller en D8 tu peux en C7 donc il
est bloqué le meilleur temporaire mais
si on décide de vraiment le sortir dans
deux couches le sort
donc on joue sur
il est là pour dominer le cavalier
adverse donc ok donc il a sauvé son fou
[Musique]
pour progresser avec le site à résoudre
les problèmes ouais bah oui oui ça c'est
très bon choix
tu as des très bons livres aussi
gagner aux échecs comment progresser aux
échecs aussi bon une fois que tu gagnes
déjà pourquoi progresser mais bon par
plaisir on va dire
tu seras très bien mais sur le site
ouais donc tout ce qui est problème
c'est nickel parce que ça va augmenter
ta vision ton ta puissance de calcul tu
as un meilleur ressenti des combinaisons
possibles et puis
et puis et puis bah ouais jouer mais
t'analise un peu tu fais pas que je veux
pour jouer essaye de revoir les parties
pas refaire les mêmes erreurs etc il va
y avoir tout revu trois H7 G4 fuj6 H5 je
me dis que l'on fait
[Musique]
dur pour Sam
non mais papiers
G4 tourner devant
un moment donné mais bon oui le truc
c'est que ouais même là il se prend pas
la tête tu prends tu prends F5 et tu
prends F7 il y a toujours le plot
raciste
très bonne partie d'ailleurs pour pour
illustrer le problème une partie de
Master Class
c'est peut-être une vidéo demain matin
ça fait un
parce que la partie elle est vraiment
bien là pour la peine on rigole on
rigole mais
c'est une super illustration
de plus bientôt 3 abandon et Sarine qui
prend les devants ok oui c'est lion qui
va pouvoir qui va s'en vouloir parce
qu'il était
il a fait une grosse gaffe dans la
première et là c'est la première partie
où il est dominé il mérite de la perdre
mais oui sur sur l'ensemble du match il
est il est très mal payé ouais
complètement en plus à priori il était
hyper bien dans la première c'est juste
on arrive au moment où il fait le dessin
avec
du coup on a pas analysé mais il
semblait que quand on arrivait juste
envoyé une barre énorme et qui
redescendu et après même là il est quand
même les moins de s'en sortir c'est
d'échanger les dames il les a gardé il a
fait la gaffe et là ça se passe mal
alors vite se remettre à l'endroit et
puis sinon bah c'est c'est la porte hein
la prochaine avec les Blancs elle va
être hyper importante pour lui
oui
ce qu'on se refait une petite pause de
10 15 minutes que tu en penses ouais on
peut faire la pause et du coup suivre un
peu la partie de Naka cette fois-ci
allez on fait dans 9 minutes allez à
tout de suite
[Musique]
on est de retour les amis alors ouais on
s'est un peu fait avoir par les horaires
désolé ça parce que ça devait reprendre
à 10 et ça reprit à 4 donc on s'est un
peu ouais un peu dépassé mon Fab
pas grave on était un peu dépassé alors
attends je vais récupérer je vais
remettre les câbles comme il faut
vas-y donc on commence par suivre un peu
Hikaru
dans ce match mais ouais marrant en fait
parce qu'ils ont rechangé
je sais pas pourquoi
c'est moi qui ai mal compris
c'est moi qui était bête c'est possible
aussi
pardon
moi j'avais compris j'avais compris que
c'était à 5 10 15 enfin tu vois qu'il
décalage à chaque fois de 5 minutes et
finalement non en fait ils sont un peu
freestyle quoi on sait pas trop
on s'est fait dépasser en plus j'ai
regardé de la pause jusqu'à l'heure du
début enfin je me suis ok ils reprennent
5 minutes avant
ça me paraissait logique bon écoute peu
importe on n'a pas raté on a même rien
raté on voit une pita lapini carreau qui
va jouer la nul
on va avoir envie de fermer le match là
maintenant bah oui oui
entendre mon complet quoi après il
aurait pu faire un banc de Claude être
un peu sport ouais beau joueur
non mais ça va pas le bon club il
utilise pas n'importe comment
ces bits avec ses viewers c'est leur
délire à eux c'est d'ailleurs de leur
commune c'est autre chose
ouais bah oui oui non il a mais bon il
aurait pu avoir envie d'en faire un
aussi
ouais mais c'est quand même pas c'est
bien qu'il est pas fait
non mais il aurait pu
être solide après on va voir comment
Douda s'en sort
toute façon il doit prendre des risques
il va tenter après c'est vrai que bon
bah la lapine c'est un très bon choix
pour les blancs pour essayer de fermer
et qui est pas trop de chance de gain en
face on va voir
la caméra plus expérimenté ouais
désolé j'ai une catastrophe dans mon
chez moi il y a Michka qui est très
énervé
qui s'est mis à Boyer dans le façon ça a
beaucoup énervé dans la cage d'escalier
bah il est pas du tout heureuse
[Musique]
après peut-être je me dis peut-être
qu'il avait mis ce clic le 3 qui voulait
faire 4 et qu'après ça m'énerve
je me demande ouais
il va prendre puis on prend entre une
Française vendent des changes ou tu fais
C4 tu joues une sorte d'anglaise tu fais
B3 bah tu fais un B3 et puis je sais pas
tu as des mener à jouer quoi c'est pas
grave enfin c'est pas grave
mais en fait c'est pas mauvais coup non
bah c'est le meilleur que j'ai 4
ça me met déjà été joué en partie longue
sérieuse pas une partie carillac un an
de caryaki ou un truc comme ça qui
arrive
3 E3 souvent mais peut-être qu'une fois
la conséquent possible
le 3e 4 4 c'est mauvais pour les blancs
oh ça doit être une variante d'avance
avec un temps de plus ça doit être
avantage blanc en réalité
je pense
que 5 D44 je pense tu fais C4 était très
bien
en plus tu as déjà l'option des quatre
c'est mieux pour les blancs c'est sûr
pour être faire play
mais vu ces réactions il en a déduit que
c'était fait exprès OK
là j'adore quoi il considère d'être
faire plein de secondes et il se dit non
[Musique]
des 5 peut-être
il y a un million en jeu pour le coup
après de toute façon c'est con enfin
quand même tu as fait E3
tu as fait 5 fois
pourquoi tu joues en fait
et dedans enfin en fait hier il a
comment dire le match aurait jamais dû
aussi mal se passer pour lui c'est juste
qu'il a perdu la deuxième partie qu'il
était gagnant et qu'il a tiltait mais en
réalité il était pas spécialement en
dominé la troisième après avec les Noirs
il a perdu quoi déjà
il s'est fait défoncer mais après il
était en full Titou ouais je sais pas il
a tilté
après il y a des joueurs qui tiltent
ionner les parties comme ça c'est pas
une partie par jour où tu as le temps de
te remettre mais
le truc c'est dans un match que tu joues
c'est pas des parties indépendantes des
autres donc tu peux pas juste une partie
enfin ça te fait jeter le match
ouais et puis après à vrai dire vu la
période actuelle et tout il y a des
trucs bon
peut-être une période plus facilement
aussi non
il joue en Bundes autrichienne
dès aujourd'hui
ouais il commence aussi jouer jeudi
et ça marche comment
[Musique]
je vais essayer de trouver
ce qu'a vrai dire c'est une belle
compétition
j'arrive à trouver nulle part tu trouves
toi non
je sais pas si mon téléphone déconne
[Musique]
je vois pas les coups
complexe
c'est rarement un bon coup de toute
façon ça c'est un commandement n'a pas
touché à spion si possible
ouais après la position est-elle que tu
veux
mettre le boxon et essayer d'attaquer le
roi là je peux comprendre autant
validé par la jauge
sûrement
ouais tout simplement si tu te donnes
dommage 5 échecs et t'attaque F5
et tu te places bien ouais tu aurais
gagné d'une RX ou y quoi non ça devait
être ça
là ça va être compliqué comme partie
bah du coup ce qu'il veut il te fait un
jeu à trois résultats il fait grand rock
il est parti se cacher là-bas
bon il a poussé ses puntos et puis on
verra bien
mais
peut se passer plein de choses c'est pas
safe c'est pas ce que vous voulez
carreaux clairement pas
ok c'est logique j'ai 5 qui veut j'ai 4
et
il faut prendre
x 4
ouais c'est hyper chaud en Fab c'est
chaud c'est très chaud complètement
tu peux pas faire genre un truc genre G4
qui est des 4 fois H2 ro H1 F4
touche le fou puis F3
tu vas peut-être te faire bloquer par G3
et c'est compliqué
très dur à calculer
c'est compliqué
intuitivement c'est ce que j'aurais fait
après c'est dur d'avoir le
le résultat entre guillemets de la ligne
joli coup en tout cas
il joue tellement mieux qu'hier écoute
ouais bah c'est un autre match en fait
complètement mais c'est vrai que hors
troll faire ses deux fois quatre parties
c'est pas mal mais c'est mieux de le
faire en deux 7 en fait du coup de faire
cette premier jour et cette de le
deuxième jour que de tout lié enfin
c'est du coup
et ça jouerait un départage
mais c'est tellement plus logique en
fait je trouve
en tout cas ça ressemble plus à nos
sports à nous européen entre guillemets
on aime bien ses formats de ça tout ça
laisse plus de chance aux gens de
revenir et c'est mieux pour le suspense
je pense sur F4 vu qu'il prend ceci on
prend et foodka non
bref
pas à mater
tu vas attaquer
aussi
quand même une très belle casse cavalier
ça me semble mais on te dit pas quatre
parties par jour tu dis de faire deux
sets de 4 parties
au lieu de faire un match de 8 parties
ça fera un joli parti mais ça te fait
2,7 distincts de quatre parties et donc
bien tu te prends 4-0 le premier jour
pas déjà ça devrait s'arrêter à 3-0
Victor est perdu le premier set le
lendemain tu reviens et puis bah c'est
comme j'utilise zéro en fait dans le
premier set bon ok je suis venu à zéro
après si je gagne cette petite septis
mais j'ai gagné le match en fait même si
j'ai gagné moins de jours au final alors
que là en fait
c'était une 6-0 c'est déjà fini quoi en
fait c'est comme sous tennis en fait on
faisait un match en 10 jeux gagnants au
lieu de faire des sets voilà c'est un
autre jeu en fait c'est un autre c'est
une manière de compter mais quelque part
pour le spectacle et tout ça c'est quand
même plus sympa les 7 et ça excuse de
suspense parce que même un mauvais jour
c'est un de revenir alors dans le sens
inverse un mauvais jour enfin jour
désastreux ou tu as trop de retard bah
tu reviens pas trop quoi
c'est bien expliqué Fab comme toujours
merci
à côté
ils arrivent à 4h à sentir tellement con
d'avoir sa mère dire je te rassure
qu'ils sont déjà con parce qu'en fait là
s'il y avait juste trois et demi en fait
avec les Noirs tu prends pas tous les
risques et tu peux gagner au blanc
et surtout qu'avec les blancs il avait
une bonne partie dans dans
dans l'attention à sa première partie
avec les Blancs étaient bonnes donc en
fait il aurait enfin le match il était
pas du tout perdu encore
c'était pas entièrement fini après
je peux le comprendre aussi mais bon
qui fait noir mais je pense pas qu'il
ait fait le malin je pense juste que il
a fait n'importe quoi
en fait je pense juste c'est dit ça me
casse les couilles et j'en ai marre
ouais mais bon
nous c'est pas faux
donc là
plus qu'on voit ça dans les tournois
encore moins les trucs qui est autant
d'argent et que tu as du public et
compagnie
à nous faire on est des grands partisans
de la petite nul
c'est quoi la défense avec les Blancs
bah le truc c'est que quand vous avez
tout prononcer 6 vous allez abîmer la
structure de pion et vous allez pouvoir
contre-attaquer c'est plus de la
contre-attaque et de l'attaque autre
chose peut-être ok
pour aller faire une petite enfilade ou
quoi donc là les blancs ils veulent pas
juste défendre leur roi oui ça c'est mal
embarqué ils ont deux pions moins faut
jouer pour autre chose mais c'est les
premiers à taper the Neo en face de la
dame qui avait allié fou qui regarde sur
ces 6 le faux 3 bien placé voilà après
c'est une raison le temps ils enlèvent
le foot D7 fondament 7 damashcard ça va
aller vite aussi donc c'est c'est parti
rock opposées en fait c'est souvent
comme ça c'est une course là sur baisser
vous l'état ma 4
mais bon tu la tourne longtemps et
il a fini par la guerre
il a réussi à pousser un à la faute
mais là parfois tu peux essayer de
repartir avec le roi de l'autre côté
mais ce qui va faire damascisse 3D 7 et
tu essayes de dans les ce qu'on dit j'ai
des trucs comme ça parfois et le roi il
est pas si facile que ça
du coup il te redécale un peu ton
attaque et pendant ce temps il a le
temps de t'attaquer
encore un matelas même si père il a
encore c'est aussi ça la différence de
score c'est que tu as la même position à
deux et demi 3 et demi c'est pas tout à
fait pareil avec les Blancs
il va faire roi des 7 j'imagine
mais là tu repars vers le 6
c'est bizarre quand on sort devant il
est pas du tout en sueur il mène quatre
deux quand même mais c'est pas étonnant
enfin pourquoi n'as qu'à serait plus
fort que Douda
c'est à peu près du même niveau en
réalité après Naka il gagne absolument
tous les tournois sur internet mais
[Musique]
bon il y a pas de raison que Douda soit
loin derrière en réalité
non plus il joue pas mal rapide
etc c'est pas une cadence où il souffre
donc là attention
ok oui
mais après il peut lui aussi repartir
vers le centre probablement faire ça
j'espère que cette tour Eiffel et faire
de
l'air pour le roi
il peut pas faire ça il peut pas il peut
faire d'un B7 mais il va repartir
après le problème c'est quoi c'est ok on
croit des 7
enfin normal donc
[Musique]
non en tout cas qui est très dangereux
qui était fort sur internet avant
c'était gris Tchouk
il était même niveau que
dans les années 2010
2005-2010 après la complètement
complètement disparu
bon il était pas mal pendant un moment
mais là c'est vrai que depuis
trois ans peut-être c'est plus dur
ouais là pour Douda ça va être dur cette
partie parce qu'il va y avoir du dame B7
c'est le plus fort en calcul il calcule
vraiment vite en son il est vraiment en
forme
il a des bonnes ouvertures
tout ça il était très affûté
7 pour couvrir le 7e
et 6 ouais
il lui manque un peu de tempo avec avec
les noirs et du manque un coup comme
souvent Rocco posé
ça se joue à des détails
comme toujours
toi aussi si je veux libérer le fou pour
aller verser 7 mais bon clairement là
c'est les blancs que l'initiative c'est
les blancs qui mettent les coups
après il a tenté le tout pour le tout
avec les Noirs
B8 pas évident mais bon faut éviter de
me baisser
du coup ouais
c'est vraiment le seul coup en fait
passons
donc tu peux le trouver parce que c'est
vraiment le seul coup
mais tu peux complètement louer le rater
aussi genre c'est pas un coup qui
devient naturellement
Théodore il fait tomber ok il reste dans
le match alors pour le moment
il est mal mais il a pas perdu
et puis il est moins mal au temps
qu'hier tu vois il est encore 3 minutes
22 il est un peu derrière mais je vais
dire si il est pas là avec ses 3
secondes
avec les Blancs elle était
catastrophique
au niveau de la gestion du temps
à gagner ouais ça va être dur mais bon
bah écoute si il avait changé avec son
recueil il a quand même plus
ok il a un argument à faire valoir voilà
là faut survivre en fait pour l'instant
c'est les deux plus forts joueurs du
tournoi personnellement Douda est Naka
et sur ce que mon Douda dans ces deux
dans cette deuxième journée je pense
qu'on s'était pas trop trompé
après
avoir si Gerry est bien préparé il peut
peut-être poser quelques problèmes à
perso pour venir frapper sur C6 et sur
des 5 mais bon qui sait fais toi
meilleur coup de l'ordi
replace sa tour
peut-être des idées de Tours pronostic
et d'amassad du coup maintenant
ouais
la position
là faut faire un petit travail
d'équilibriste pour pour du
mais bon je peux pas trop de gains
je change la tour je prends C6 il y aura
des sets à la fin
et on perd le flou donc
on a pas un moyen simple de se dire bon
ok je fais ça et puis je ferai nul au
pire ouais non enfin trouvé encore des
trucs ici après là les trois minutes de
diff elles vont faire mal même si la
mieux équilibré son temps qu'hier
j'ai peur que ce soit sans phase trop
pour lui
c'est quand les demi ce sera vendredi
samedi à la finale dimanche lundi
c'est tout le temps de jour
aujourd'hui répété à chaque fois beau
format
non
plus
E
je crois que ça termine
ok c'est qui roule le faible et leur
mère était sa victoire sur l'ensemble du
match bien sûr mais
pardon aura donné une meilleure image
aujourd'hui et
en fait dès qu'on regarde une partie la
paire quoi ouais
[Musique]
à travailler un truc qui semblait juste
évident comme match se terminer dès la
5e partie il a poussé le match jusqu'à
jusqu'à la septième ronde c'est pas mal
mais cette fois-ci va s'incliner
bah là c'est terminé
parce que la tour aussi sera clouée et
là il y a le feu 5 qui est attaqué donc
il y en a qui arrive de partout
ok oui et finalement l'attaque blanche a
été la plus rapide
ça sentait ouais qu'il est qu'il avait
un petit gain un petit tempo d'avance
mais après ça c'était la bonne décision
pour pour Jean-Christophe une erreur est
si vite arrivée
mais là maintenant c'est une qualité de
moi et
il y a plus du tout de jeu
il va sûrement échanger une paire de
tour et faire d'âme C8 non
professionnel
puisqu'on pas au tennis c'était le
dernier match de Gilou aujourd'hui il a
perdu contre
oglassim
donc bravo pour sa carrière quoi après
peut-être qu'il va ça lui donne envie de
rentrer un peu non je crois pas enfin
j'ai lu son interview en fait que il dit
que oui il peut encore faire un match ou
deux pas mal de temps il a bien joué à
Roland il a bien joué ici mais qu'en
fait il peut plus jouer comme un joueur
pro est censé le faire 52 semaines par
an parce que il a trop de douleurs et
voilà là en fait il s'entraînait comme
un fou pour essayer d'être à peu près en
forme ici et dit qu'il a des douleurs
partout etc et qui peut plus avoir
la régularité la régularité voilà et que
ce genre de tennis c'est que tu vas sur
le circuit tous les jours enfin
quasiment tu vois et que ça peut plus
faire donc il dit voilà là ça 180
huitième place mondiale elle est méritée
c'est juste son niveau du moment et que
pas de regrette partir là quoi tu vois
enfin comme ça c'est bien il est content
d'avoir pu faire un bon dernier Roland
un bon dernier Bercy et finir comme ça
quoi mais
physiquement gros ça tient plus ça je
suis plus quoi c'est normal
ce sera un bon coach à mon avis ouais
ouais
bah c'est vrai qu'il a fait une
incroyable enfin
il était 8e Mondial
2008 je dirais mais
à Montréal non ou aussi je sais pas
quand c'est la deuxième mais il a fait
et alors que tu le vois pas de confort
en fait
c'est juste qu'il
sciences du jeu il faisait raté il
remettait beaucoup il est il courait
bien et puis contrairement
mentalement très très fort bon voilà
enfin c'est beau d'avoir optimisé autant
ses capacités
c'est très beau mais même aujourd'hui la
pète est ridicule j'ai un petit peu
regardé
le score un peu lourd mais bon il faut
aller les chercher ces jeux en face sans
modulo
avec des gens blouses et tout en plus il
fait du faire ce qu'il pouvait avec les
moyens du bord quoi
bonjour
qui termine sa carrière
et Douda lui qui en termine avec ce
tournoi
ça y est c'est terminé
qu'il l'emporte allez on va aller voir
les autres parties qu'est-ce qui se
passe côté Raja BOV
quel est le noir qui souffre a priorité
non non au contraire Fab il a des blancs
en arrière
c'est mauvais je vais pas la position
j'avais le château
donc on se doute bien que ça devrait
bien se passer
voilà et on va aller jeter juste un
œil à l'autre partie
qui peut être égalisé à son tour
magnifique
on va voir des armagues dans tous les
sens
ok oui
on reste sur quoi sur les cames
ouais n'importe quoi
donc ça ça guéri guéri
et
c'est beau quand même si ce qualifie
Raja bof
bah surtout que là
donc belle réaction d'orgueil ok oui
c'est pas fait encore
une égalisation donc il peut se passer
plein de choses encore après mais
Punto
une grosse avance matérielle quand même
attaque de maths
le gastronomanculote court ton sueur il
menait deux points lui aussi
allez c'est pas encore complètement fait
il a pas récupéré le pion
encore
ouais mais hyper B4 il va pas la gagner
en plus en fait il s'est trouvé
[Musique]
en fait
voilà ça a vraiment mal joué sur ce
qu'on a vu
trois tours ouais non tu avais que
attends non bah oui de toute façon c'est
le Piona qui restera à la fin au cas où
je crois que c'est juste bizarre en fait
comme coup il vient
et rien
t'arriver ouais ben non
sur le pire puisse arriver c'est ça
je m'y attendais pas en fait parce que
je dis ok juste là tu stand en fait je
pensais moi bien roi juste bêtement
jusque là et tu continues
alors attends il peut essayer ça
[Musique]
va regarder l'autre match
et de bouger
trois aussi mais c'est con
mais après même ces trois tours c'est
pas si con et du coup je l'Europe quand
il y aura ses quatre tours des quatre
échecs
il vient jamais si tu veux pas en fait
pas là on fait exprès de vraiment faire
les cons pour le laisser faire mais tu
fais ça tu repars et puis si il passe la
4e tu me mets en échec quoi
il va prendre il va venir en B3 et puis
bon
ça peut être chiant ça
tu peux dire que il va te faire chier
mais bon en fait ça marche jamais non
incroyable hein
qu'il a complètement raté et qui guéri
notre blessure
rien à faire pour faire une il l'a donné
quoi ouais c'était archi nul après au vu
de la partie c'est normal mais en
passant par là et comme ça c'est juste
étonnant
[Musique]
bon on va suivre ça là je sais pas ce
que j'ai le temps de mettre les cas moi
j'ai le temps de mettre les cames
donc c'est Vion qui joue pour égaliser
et qui a quatre que faire regardez
toutes ces pièces à l'attaque les deux
fous braquer vers le RER sur le théorème
des fous
[Musique]
il y a même pas de pion de moi quoi
c'est juste de l'attaque gratos le
cavalier attaque la dame la tour toutes
les pièces attaques les 5 pièces à
l'attaque
je crois trop pas mal joué pas très bien
joué ça va éliminer ce qui est G5 qui
est un peu la seule pièce autour du roi
attention quand même champion
quelques conneries
mais la barre était très heureux
c'est la même position mais avec ta pas
de pièce de bois
bon ben écoute trop de gaffe de ces
viandes trop de manque de réalisme
énormément de gaffe croûte
la partie basse du tableau de façon
visuellement c'était déjà nettement
moins fort
que la partie haute et
3 faut faire entre 100
tu rajoutes du monde à l'attaque tu as
pas le choix
[Musique]
un peu quand même encore
on va voir comment ça se conclure
mais bon avec deux secondes de rajout
on va voir ce qui est réussi à faire
ça va être sympa les speeds cette année
oui
qui joue bah ça je sais pas mais je me
disais en fait
comparativement tu vois
[Musique]
non
bah ouais ouais
en vrai genre demain on dirait tiens un
match
non c'est bien c'est cool ça reprenne
c'est toujours un événement un peu
marquant de la saison et c'est cool
pareil tu vois c'est pas c'est pas le
temps de l'année non plus mais non
aussi
tu te friandises qu'au milieu de la
saison comme ça
un peu plus calme qui est plus gros de
tournoi tu dirais tiens on va se
regarder un petit speech ici ou là il
était sympa le match de Maxime l'an
dernier contre
contre
Fabi
ah oui
mais genre c'était un beau match
vous êtes absolument dégoûté c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est sûr que c'était plus intéressant
clairement non mais c'est sûr que
c'était mieux mais bon après
[Musique]
tu as pas réussi à faire grand-chose en
réalité
[Musique]
la seule chance c'est de passer par
oui bon ça sert à rien en fait ça c'est
complètement nul
et
je pense
a réussi
je pensais mais je sais pas c'est de
faire à 5 ou tout début
4e
pile poil attend nul et l'autre ça va ou
tu as pas le temps
ça c'est nul pas trop le temps avec
l'autre
[Musique]
ouais donc il y avait encore moyen d'un
peu jouer le gars ça peut se tromper
c'est pas évident
tu vas pas t'amuser en fait
mais ouais gros raté de ces viandes
s'échapper la proie une fois de plus et
ça va peut-être faire trop il a
tellement laissé échapper enfin il a
laissé échapper peut-être trois points
enfin 3/2 points mais du coup
en fait déjà
c'est pas notre problème
ce serait Maxime on serait énervé quand
même oui oui on est là regarde comme ça
quoi
les bonnes cames alors guériora les
noirs
les blancs moi j'espère que va gagner du
coup
ce serait bien fait pour
pour Gary
je vais déjà préparer en fait tout pour
que ce soit en place tu vois
très bien
et après on aura peut-être un petit
armagidon si on a du bol Fab
le rêve le rêve
bon allez let's go la pause Fab et on
revient dans une cardeur
[Musique]
mon est de retour mais on sait pas à
quelle heure ça reprend ben non dans la
certitude mais bon
mais je sais pas j'ai vu qu'il remettez
en 2 minutes 30 ce match là enfin on
arrive pas à savoir on sait pas du tout
c'est pas il y a pas de il y a pas de
logique je peux pas comprendre comme ça
en fait c'est pas possible il y a pas de
suivi logique mais je suis très heureux
quoi j'ai vu il y a une supporters je
crois que c'est de Manchester
ils t'ont fait une chanson Harry Maguire
your des fan sistery
ils sont très heureux quoi
[Musique]
arrive à Goya
mais il est si nul que ça
ouais il est pas très rassurant comme
défenseur
tu te dis crasso pour lui faire très mal
quoi mais comment ça se fait qu'il est
titulaire à Manchester je sais pas
[Musique]
le ballon est pas vraiment son ami
il te rassure pas enfin tu préfères
qu'on t'a Varane qui est là quoi mais
non mais j'ai vu un but extraordinaire
en plus c'est hier en fait un mec qui
frappe la balle va complètement aller
dans le bus et en fait ma gwayer il a
pas de bol quoi il a fait il est juste
sur le chemin quoi
ils peuvent absolument rien faire juste
il a des vies on peut entendre
et du coup c'est marrant sur la vidéo il
y a il fait il fait un cri quoi ah oui
Maguire
il a coûté très cher
oui
je me rends pas compte je me rends pas
compte je crois que c'était pas donné
ouais
aussi une interview d'un gamin qui
supporter de Manchester mais je sais pas
il y a peut-être 7 8 ans quoi
le période avec Giggs enfin ici quelques
ici quelques joueurs quoi ils vont à
Maguire quoi
j'étais fan comme Murtas là fin des
années 90 c'était beau hein
mais devant c'était hier qui est cool je
crois les deux les deux en point
c'est une gamme qui pouvait rentrer
ils sont corrects mais c'est plus le
Manchester United qui qui marchait sur
l'Angleterre quoi c'est un peu plus
compliqué maintenant ceux qui ont
progresser c'est autonome non maintenant
ils sont stables non bonne équipe
Ronald Zouba zubarbe à l'OM ouais je me
rappelle de ça a complètement nul lui
voilà normal quoi tu vois mais pas
un joueur qui est un peu marqué c'était
Gabian il m'a un peu marqué
PSG avant
excellent lui bah très pro la grinta il
était bon
il t'apportait beaucoup c'est bien
[Musique]
c'était beau hein
français à l'époque tu as du Guerry
c'était pas mal hein
danger beaucoup
ouais non mais il était bon il se crée
[Musique]
tous les deux finir en équipe de France
stable milieu de terrain c'est ça ouais
on les voyait comme
après il y a eu un bip bye c'était un
peu plus
tard bon commentateur maintenant c'est
un bon défenseur valeureux
centrale aussi mais c'était un peu moins
ça
moi je trouve qu'il était pas mauvais
hein
après c'est juste qu'il est resté très
longtemps et genre il t'en ont fait un
genre de défenseur emblématique alors
que oui enfin c'est
qui était venu faire une pige
pas mal de choses
[Musique]
il était pas venu non je pense pas
il avait remplacé Lizarazu à gauche à
Munich
ouais
pour le coup en fait mais en fait dans
l'esprit c'est ça c'était le successeur
de Lizarazu comme un latéral de nuit
il est vraiment bon
mais Marseille là c'est un peu kata
cette saison non c'est genre il y a eu
un très gros début et ouais ça va moins
bien bah là c'est con Ligue des
Champions pas ok
à 94e toutes les coupes d'Europe un peu
c'est un peu dommage et donc ouais ils
sont dans le dur après avoir s'il sort
de la crise ou s'ils s'en foutent
mais ils ont une belle équipe ils sont
ridicule
et qui pas mal après je sais pas je suis
pas tous les matchs tu vois mais je sais
que tu dors il fait pas son lien de
limiter l'entraîneur parce que il fait
des choix derrière enfin il y a
avant-hier il a pas fait jouer
paillettes les gens sont plaignaient un
peu à se dire ouais mais bon quand même
tu peux le faire rentrer un moment il va
te mettre un ballon au milieu puis ça va
il est pas encore fini paillettes il
plus flamboyant mais il peut encore
bonne question
ah oui oui en fait c'est marrant c'est
horrible il parlait déjà de vieille tu
dors avant que ça commence et puis en
fait
jusqu'à il y a un mois de ça ça va bien
ils ont quasiment tout gagné les gars et
là j'enchaîne un peu les couilles
après c'est depuis la défaite contre
Ajaccio à domicile non c'est ça qui
était pas trop visible
en fait moralement puisque après ils ont
enchaîné exactement
dans la mauvaise dynamique
les grosses équipes ont du mal en France
sont plus si grosses en fait
Lyon Sud
Talence qui travaille bien en fait il
progresse bien d'un année alors après ce
qu'ils vont arriver à se stabiliser à
long terme du radiaire mais ça se passe
très bien depuis 2 ans quand même pour
rien c'est beau ce qu'ils font bon là tu
as Lorient c'est pas ce qu'ils font là
ils jouent bien en fait mais c'était pas
trop prévisible bon après tu as tout le
temps de Paris de façon aussi tu peux
pas les toucher et après les autres ont
du mal à
mais en fait c'est peut-être dur aussi
de bâtir une un gros truc quand tu sais
que tu joue pas le titre
c'est la question que je voulais te
poser en fait
peut-être que ça fait un peu genre
nouveau
ils vont peut-être faire une énorme
équipe en fait c'est pas trop le cas
quoi il faut une équipe bon tu sens que
normalement tu vas pas trop suer pour
descendre mais est-ce que ils attendent
que peut-être il est plus de les Kataria
Paris pour se dire allez c'est le moment
on envoie ou est-ce que ils veulent
juste faire ça enfin j'en sais rien en
fait mais c'est vrai que tu te dis que
là peut-être j'envoie à fond perdu pour
probablement pas être champion autant
que j'assure je m'en fous puis je garde
un peu en réserve si une opportunité
j'en sais rien ça c'est un questionnaire
après de toute façon le foot ça a fond
perdu non ça sert à rien
ouais bon après tu viens de titres tu es
quand même content c'est ça peut-être
rien mais ça te fait des souvenirs
non ouais je sais pas ce qu'ils veulent
il est au soir je connais pas trop là
le projet du groupe
on demande si la SS ça va mieux ou pas
ça va un peu mieux dans le sens on a
gagné le dernier match de championnat
après ça va pas du jour relégal donc ça
va très mal en fait ça va pas ouf mais
c'est dur c'est dur je dis même pas
qu'on va s'en sortir ou quoi j'en sais
rien j'ai pas l'impression que les mecs
fassent pas les efforts ils ont
peut-être pas trop compris ce qu'il
fallait faire au début ils sont sûrement
vu trop beaux ils ont cru bon ok on
descend de Ligue 1 ça va aller pas trop
et
je sais pas mais bon
pas les enfants c'est on verra
problème c'est que la direction n'a pas
bougé donc c'est toujours le même avis
sur quoi
c'est compliqué hein
très compliqué Fabien
c'est extrêmement
de malus ce serait pas légal on serait
pas beau non plus tu vois enfin ça va
pas finir le championnat et dire oui on
a appelé moins trop au début quand même
sur très différent c'est que moi trois
points donc si à la fin tu rates la
montée parce qu'il te manque un point ou
quoi tu pourras râler mais là en fait
c'est juste que de toute façon dans les
bas-fonds quoi
quoi qu'il en soit voilà tu râles pas du
tout non
je préférerais les avoir parce
moralement au moins tu dis tu es parler
légal et ça te laisse une petite bouée
de mais tu vois tu fais une saison de
merde dans tous les cas quoi enfin ça on
peut être honnête quand même quoi
de toute façon tu joues pas le maintien
non c'est ça
enfin tu joues pas le maintien de dire
les moins 3 peuvent pas tout expliquer
là c'est évidemment tu es un peu moins
soeur un peu tête tu rates un peu de
championnat tu dis ah merde quand même
bon à un moment tu gagnes un match ah
bah tu es comme à zéro bon mais ça va
quand même pas trop bon
[Musique]
tu dégages quoi
non mais je crois que tu nous aurais mis
des plots en face on a perdu aussi on se
barrage
et ça a pas été volé
quoi qu'il en soit
personnel champion cette année
ouais
le génie donc forcément ça aide
alors ça reprend encore nos histoires là
je pense sont décalés
on va pas attendre ça il joue plus on va
pas attendre la caille joue plus enfin
qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quoi
par plus ils vont te décaler le truc ils
vont te faire de l'armée Guédon jusqu'à
23h ça
complexe
c'est très complexe
non mais là je comprends pas pourquoi ça
déjà de base dès qu'elle est bon si on
veut mais bon la rigueur je peux
comprendre quand à quatre matchs tu veux
un peu voir le début de chacun bon
admettons enfin je suis pas fan de
l'idée mais bon allez là tu attends quoi
en fait
là on attend pour attendre il se passe
absolument rien
bon voilà
c'est parti au moins pour
j'ai juste le chat en plein milieu
j'enlève ma joie en fait sur le retour
nickel merci parfait
je suis à terre le chat
tu vois ça va arriver un jour ce truc
bon on remarque
pourquoi pas
je sais pas moi ce serait beau j'ai
quasi envie de reprendre les échecs pour
le faire en fait
pour voir quoi c'est ça la Nim Zoé
c'est ça c'était pas dragosine enfin je
sais pas ouais mais si
comme c'est une transposition si je
considère c'est la personne mon skinzo
j'ai pas envie de l'embêter avec la Rago
tu vois
je sais pas ce que toi tu en penses
mais ça c'est le même genre d'idée
ça appartient
la famille des Nino
la grande famille des Nimzo
avec la petite sœur à gozine
exactement
ce n'est pas vrai
ouais c'est un sous-branche de
il a tous les coups du tennis
tiens on nous dit ouais c'est vrai que
en Formule 1 il arrive de pisser aussi
au volant
bah tu me diras c'est vrai qu'un grand
prix est long et tu fais comment si tu
as vraiment envie de pisser
un petit bidon
c'est pas bien tu as ta combi et tout
comment ça se passe c'est une bonne
question
une couche je pense pas que tu es une
couche que tu as déjà tellement peu de
place
c'est comme ça quoi je sais que
tu te pisse dessus
prennent et tout je peux pas te retenir
de pisser en fait
c'est sûr ouais en fait juste une pisse
dessus en fait
mais c'est dur je pense de se pisser
dessus
non je pense c'est psychologique tu as
une retenue psychologique mais je pense
que quand tu fais un truc où tu es
obligé de le faire après avec l'habitude
ça doit
je pense qu'on se lance là puis c'est
sur l'adversaire après la fin de la
partie c'est pas facile
aujourd'hui ils ne le font pas en fait
ils sont ils ont du mal à s'hydrater
pendant une course siège du pilote se
trouve juste devant le moteur entre les
deux radiateurs et il porte un casque et
plusieurs couches de vêtements résistant
au feu de sorte que copines une voiture
de F1 devient très chaud les pilotes
peuvent faire plusieurs kilos de points
en transpiration pendant une course et
finisse généralement assez déshydraté à
la fin ok ouais donc globalement en fait
ils perdent tellement d'eau qui peuvent
plus pisser donc
du coup tu te vide bien avant avant la
course ça peut être bien sûr et puis
après tu roules tu as chaud tu sues et
ça va
ok certains pilotes pis ok ok je sors
1h40 1h40
avec enfin je pense que tu peux pas
l'épicer 5 minutes avant le départ quoi
tu vas quand même aller vers la voiture
et tout donc
mais tout ça doit être étudié peut-être
avec des médecins ou quoi qui leur
disent tu peux voir telle quantité enfin
ça se trouve il faut vraiment des tests
pour pour pas qu'ils aient trop envie
quand ils sont en course enfin j'en sais
rien en fait c'est des questions je me
suis jamais posé mais ça serait pas
absurde de bien être sûr d'éviter que le
scénario puisse doivent se produire mais
en tout cas pas être pris de course si
jamais c'est ça qui est intéressant sur
ces lives c'est qu'on a le temps de se
poser des questions Fab
bah oui dans toutes ses pauses
en fait j'ai tellement de règles
différentes comme ça change à chaque
fois
mais je suis très heureux de l'armée
si tu as pissé 5 minutes dans le départ
mais par exemple Michael Schumacher pour
emmerder son rival des curry il bloquer
les chiottes c'est arrivé à Nico Rosberg
OK et quel intérêt du coup c'est juste
pour l'emmerder
en fait faut vraiment être un tel
connard pour faire ça
nous on aurait fait à chaque course je
pense arrêter terrible
il y avait une des défioles de pis tu
avais été envoyé dessus je crois
dans le public ouais je crois ouais
petite fille
après il y a les disques aussi hein
partie trop tôt il passait sur le chat
d'ailleurs
c'est c'est marrant mais il est passé
peut-être un mois avant avant
un peu discuté et tout ouais je lui
avais dit magnifique tes vidéos et tout
les repas et tout extraordinaires
partie trop tôle pueblo c'était vraiment
bien quoi
il est passé au moins quatre cinq fois
dans le chat
parti trop tôt malheureusement
un jeune qui nous a fait passer de
d'excellents moments
oui
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on a pu rire grâce aux pub
il est pas mort il y a eu un truc il y a
quelques jours à un moment que c'était
c'était un fake
c'est pas un fake super marrant si
jamais enfin je préfère que ce soit fake
si c'est un fake c'était de plus mauvais
goût possible
que c'était réel
mais non il était passé il passait il
passait regarder un peu des échecs quoi
mais il était jeune il était 25 ans
qu'est-ce qu'il a pu nous faire rire
des belles vidéos à l'époque
c'était le bon YouTube
les gens c'était pas on n'était pas
forcément au courant ouais
on a pu la voir passer sur Twitter ou
quoi selon
mais bon faut faudra Twitter il faut
suivre
Twitter et tout mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas une information ouais ça a pas
fait la une des journaux alors que il
était quand même très suivi il y a quand
même beaucoup de gens qui le
connaissaient quoi
c'est quel polo c'est quelqu'un qui
avait une chaîne de cuisine et sur
Youtube
ça vient de lui
c'est pas ça marque
cuisine
à une petite nul magnifique
je pense que je vais je vais aller voir
après mais je pense que ça doit jouer
dans une heure à l'Armageddon ici
on va pouvoir suivre Sarine c'est bien
alors
il a pas encore fait baisser mais avant
c'était complètement horizon qui vient
de pousser le Pione 5 il y a de rompre
un commandement mais excellent très bien
c'est bien qui joue le tout pour le tout
si vous connaissez pas
vous pouvez voir des belles recettes
il passait réellement
nos fake no fake qui passait je vais pas
dire régulièrement mais de temps à autre
y passer je vois un peu aux échecs
on aurait pu faire faire un match contre
gouv HD quoi
à sa vidéo avec elle pueblo non mais il
est le contrat
il avait nettoyé les chiottes au final
ou pas
je sais pas trop
vaguement je pense mais bon
très bon youtubeur magnifique ouais
il faisait aussi des dégustations de
Coca-Cola de 1960
excellent
youtubeurs là
je me rappelle on attendait que les
vidéos sortaient tout quand il aille
chez le poème avec le contrat le machin
ah bah oui
il a signé le contrat les règles
c'était la belle époque
bon ça me séviant qui a bien remis
repris ses esprits qui a bien fait
baisser
c'était vraiment extraordinaire quoi
qu'il avait pas livré chez lui non
c'était pas bon
[ __ ]
quand même il y a un gars qui a contacté
la mairie et vu le personnage ça se
pourrait ça m'étonnerait quand même
enfin j'espère honnêtement mais
pas trop enfin oui je vois pas trop
l'intérêt
tant mieux en fait si c'est ça mais
je crois pas
non c'est pas dans le ça c'est pas le
genre de chose avec lequel on rigole
ouais non c'était c'était une période
mais il avait bu l'eau du Gange et tout
il était même pas tombé malade
ouais mais je pense qu'avec toutes ces
recettes il avait un super système
immunitaire quoi du coup
improbable
tu vas aller checker sa chaîne enfin je
veux dire elle est j'espère qu'il y a
encore toutes les vidéos et toutes les
recettes
mais après c'était un peu fait pourrir
par les marques aussi raconter mais bon
parce que c'est quand il a écouté le
saumon Labeyrie
quand même
c'est dur de voilà vaut mieux rester
bien
évoluer trop et tu es très content de ce
que tu manges mais ouais il y a plus
rien de philosophie ça quand même elle
est fermée sa chaîne Youtube
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
chaîne sans contenu ils ont tout viré
mais donc ils ont décidé probablement de
supprimer toutes les vidéos
de voir
il y a plus rien enfin il y a la chaîne
existe mais il est vide
écoute je sais pas
on sait pas quelles étaient ces
volontaires à lui non plus on peut pas
on peut pas juger comme avec beaucoup de
choses
autant c'est lui qui avait demandé que
c'est pas
c'est un choix qu'il faut respecter
exactement
ça se respecte complètement
cette partie on va attendre c'est une
ruse ça ruse ici quoi
qu'il a été facile quand même après il
s'est laissé un peu surprendre à la
reprise de la journée mais il a bien
fermé le match
ouais bon journée mais ça suffit il a
fait le taf on va dire
ce qui compte l'important c'est la
calife
c'est les trois points
faire
une nulle et il était peut-être il a
peut-être été un peu pris de court et
en tout cas
on va avoir ce match là ça Rinne à mon
avis qui va être facile pour se
qualifier il pourra aller jusqu'en final
il y a un tableau assez ouvert
je trouve en tout cas Fabien
sur ce qu'on a vu mais
bon de toute façon le bagarre de ce
match sera plutôt challenger en 2000
mais
bon il y a quand même la place pour
essayer de faire un truc il y a la place
hein
il y a plus que la place femme
bon en tout cas voilà c'est violent il a
une partie où toutes les pièces sont là
bon après c'est assez symétrique ou quoi
mais ça peut cliquer pendant de nombreux
coups c'est dur tout échanger donc il
fait pas nul en claquant des doigts avec
les Blancs c'est l'idée alors je
sécurise
et ça peut suffire
on nous demande pourquoi Naka a fini son
match Fab
parce qu'il a
il avait marqué à 7 points pour gagner
quoi qu'il arrive
c'est un match où il y a 8 parties en
tout c'est à partir du moment où tu as
marqué plus de 4 points de gagner et
donc là le tournoi a pris le parti de ne
pas faire jouer des parties inutiles
dans le sens inutile
s'il y a déjà un vainqueur qui a 4 et
demi ou si je joue cinq parties qu'un
joueur gagne 5 parties ils comprennent
bien qu'il reste plus que trois il y a
pas de points négatif possible donc au
mieux il y aura 5 3 il a gagné il a
gagné voilà terminé
donc voilà
c'est pas toujours le cas parfois on
fait jouer les parties pour rien oui bah
c'est ça enfin pour le coup bonne
initiative de ne pas le faire
signaler quand il y a des bonnes
décisions de prise on aurait pu un
décider de faire quand même jouer les
parties pour être bien sûr bien les
décaler en grand format
ok oui
est-ce que le joueur qui impressionne le
plus en ce moment
dur à dire en fait non mais en rapide
tout ça il joue vraiment bien là
[Musique]
c'était pas mal ce qu'il avait fait il
est très bien joué
là il était très bon donc non il a
impressionnant après le truc c'est que
pour que allez on je
desserre entre guillemets un grand mot
mais ce titre là est très impressionnant
j'ai envie de le voir en partie dans les
gros tournois
tu vois s'il va te faire ça
j'en sais rien
il était pas mal mais du coup il a pas
gagné ça a pas été le plus
impressionnant ah non il est tout à
l'heure
donc voilà j'attends qu'il nous fasse ça
dans un tournoi de calibre là et là bon
il y aura rien à dire
sur la liste très bien ce qu'il fait
enfin je sais pas pour diminuer sa
prestation mais
voilà pour avoir
ça reste du tournoi internet quoi pour
toi ici
mais c'est déjà c'est déjà
impressionnant ce qu'il fait enfin en
fait c'est pas le problème mais
mais c'est pas ça se prend comme tennis
c'est pas ce que je peux regarder
le plus du coup sur cette saison si on
enlève la victoire des candidats donc
mes pots et on va dire Carlson parce que
champion du monde quitte impressionne le
plus hors de ces deux joueurs au monde
sinon
[Musique]
pas le droit de dire
le problème tu vois de base tu aurais
dit plutôt fioul jazz sur ce qui se
passe depuis un an mais en fait son
tournoi des candidats l'impression
non mais du coup on fait des trucs très
impressionnants mais du coup on compte
pas les candidats du tout en fait
parce que Ding en fait il a pas joué à
parler candidats donc il y a deux fêtes
il peut pas être compter et firuja si tu
pourras dire ni Carlson il est quatrième
mondiale là donc il est là et le fait
qu'il soit qualifié dès le
tournoi Riga ce qu'il avait fait avec
l'équipe de France au championnat
d'Europe etc il a très très bien joué
après juste il a fait une énorme pause
pour préparer justement les candidats et
c'est pas bien passé donc
tu mettras un bémol quand même quoi bah
c'est dur en fait de pas compter les
candidats du coup tu vois ce que je veux
dire en fait ça a tellement impacté la
saison le choix du calendrier des
joueurs et finalement quand on avait vu
le tournoi Bucarest ou avant ou les mecs
qui jouent les candidats je vais avec le
frein à main ils vont pas les préparer
donc forcément tu vas pas être méga
impressionnant si tu joues pas à 100 %
donc et donc en comptant les candidats
c'est qui le plus impressionné à part un
pot
ok il tient ou peut-être c'est pas mal
quand même carreau parce que en fait ça
qui sort nulle part il est pas juste
parti longue depuis des années il se
qualifie candidat il est tout sauf
ridicule et il fait tous ces trucs à
côté sur internet donc pourquoi pas
il a montré toute la panoplie à droite à
gauche
c'est un choix qui se défend mais une
place de troisième au championnat du
monde de Blitz non c'est pas mal
ambition
il mériterait enfin
truc que je trouve pas si impressionnant
en général quoi c'est parti ou quoi mais
candidat il a tellement marché sur le
tournoi et pareil on parle des
championnats du monde de Blitz et de
rapides du coup il a fait promis execo
il a juste perdu le départage contrat
d'où ça t'auras mais il était pas loin
d'arcitres là il a fait final 960 enfin
il est quand même assez régulièrement là
on peut dire qu'il choisit vraiment ses
échéances ouais mais les gros trucs et
il est là il les ratte pas quoi c'est
pas il les coches il passe à côté c'est
quand
ça compte que ça joue gros il
est bien quoi alors après évidemment
plus fort que lui c'est tout en fait
donc là tu as beaucoup d'échéance
tu fais ce que tu peux tu te prends un
mur quoi mais c'est l'inverse de Douda
en fait
c'est ça
quelque part
ça commence à suer encore 1%
il commence à venir roder il va leur H4
G3
potentiellement y aller mais je vais
clairement là c'était une menace
d'enfilade donc faut faire quelque chose
et
tu conserveront un peu
faible
puissance active
ça se passe
comme les Noirs l'espérée c'est pas
gagné pour autant mais
quand tu commences ton ouverture par
faire aussi des six G6 bon enfin je suis
cool là si on dit que 20 coups après tu
as ça tu signe mais c'est largement quoi
il m'a quand même l'air d'être Sarine un
peu juste pour les demi mais bon
franchement dans le niveau de jeu il est
en dessous de ce que c'est bien après
mais comme on a dit et aucun réalisme
mais la partie d'avant qui doit gagner
il devrait déjà être ne pas être
derrière il a complètement en galvaudé
la position et
et donc
ouais tabou est mieux dans le jeu si
avant tu gagnes pas quand tu dois gagner
et que tu fais des gaffes bah ça se paye
non mais là il a fait full gaffe dans le
match
Sarine qui confirme pas les espoirs
qu'on place en lui je veux dire par là
en partie réelle
non non
[Musique]
parce qu'il plante ces petites peaux de
bananes ou quoi mais ouais il est devenu
dans le jeu donc il joue moins bien que
c'est bien dans le fond de jeu en tout
cas sur ce ouais sur ce slash sur ce
match
on dit dommage que ceux et Carus
rencontrent en 2000 semblent de plus
solide je pense que Douda aussi c'est
parti on va dire
non mais du coup
je suis un peu enfin c'est pas simple
soit en 2000 bah pareil puis au final de
toute façon tu te prends un mec s'il
allait jusque-là c'est que c'est pas
fait d'avance non plus
Naka si gagne une tournante en tout cas
il a vraiment un parcours difficile il
sera vraiment une chercher
je sais pas contre qui c'était qualifié
avant sur Internet et puis
mais Douda ouais il est dommage pour lui
de pas être bien rentré dans le tournoi
quoi
ouais
pas suffi mais bon on aurait pu avoir un
match plus discuté quoi qu'il en soit on
aurait dû quoi
il a perdu contre ses viandes
on disait il prend pas au sérieux ces
tourments Internet
pas assez peut-être
parce qu'au final il y a quand même de
belles sommes en jeu
cette partie et après les armagues
tu penses qu'ils vont faire un pari pour
avoir très peu de temps guérir à jabov
comme ils font beaucoup de nuls
le problème c'est que je sais pas
combien les blancs de temps
je trouve l'info
est-ce que j'ai déjà gagné une caméra
ouais plusieurs fois mais bon j'ai
beaucoup joué aussi c'est normal
la plus belle restera la carrocane
de plus en deux coups
moderne ou quoi une nouvelle partie quoi
l'autre c'est vraiment
c'était vraiment un bel accomplissement
parce que faut aller le battre dans un
genre de partie
j'en ai mis une belle André qui aussi à
deux semaines
j'ai pas vu pour le coup mais elle était
encore peut-être plus
vraiment une bonne partie
hier soir j'ai bêtement raté ça
mais bon
en direct mais j'ai vu après
non comme partie aussi
un style dangereux quand les mecs c'est
attendent pas je sais pas comment dire
non mais d'autant plus quand les gens
s'y attendent pas
oui oui bien sûr bah c'est sûr que c'est
toujours bien que j'ai compris quelqu'un
qui est moins vigilant qui te prend de
haut et qui se dit oui bon il dit pas
très ça va aller
mais j'ai même ceux qui s'y attendent
enfin genre tu vois on a un cas ou quoi
il dit je vais me
comme il joue pas de tournoi IRL les
mecs ça fait qui c'est quoi donc à force
maintenant bon tu vois au début stream
depuis les années dans le monde de
tournois les Arena Kings les machins je
veux dire même ceux qui n'ont jamais
croisé en vrai ils commencent à voir
passer le pseudo et je pense c'est moins
sous-estimé en tout cas mais un mec
comme ça qui débarque qui en sait rien
il doit moins se méfier que s'il tombe
sur sur un joueur qu'il a peut-être déjà
vu des parties dans les bases on se
préparant ou je sais pas quoi ou qu'il a
déjà croisé les open ou dans je ne sais
donc c'est en ce sens là que oui on peut
s'estimer mais mais bon c'est quand même
moins le cas enfin
c'est
pas comme il y a trois quatre cinq ans
normalement ils font 4 bandes par
exemple c'est sûr qu'il fait gaffe
j'ose pas
entière
en tournoi je veux dire
aussi mais j'avais une pièce de plus
j'étais
enfin
j'essaye
pas toujours facile
non non
stop c'était 28 je sais pas quoi 20
peut-être et puis même là je tourne 2007
je bouge pas bon après je suis pas en
trahirty hard mais bon je clique un peu
et
j'ai mal à décoller quoi après il jouait
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours comme je fais ça fait vraiment
progresser à force je le sens le seul
problème c'est que du coup avec les
tournois les machins les vidéos et tout
je suis souvent fatigué donc ça c'est
pas bien non plus on va dire que ça fait
tellement progresser à force de le faire
tous les jours que ouais le jour où je
vais le reposer c'est sûr que je vais
être nettement plus fort qu'avant
technique de Bachi je mets des chics en
petits
je vais plus vite non tu vois mieux
l'échiquier mais bon
les cases elles sont moins loin
tu peux rapetisser tu
ah ouais ok il est où ce truc comme ça
il est en bas à droite
elles sont plus proches donc
il est loin quoi
mais c'est vrai que tu vois tu as
certaines dis c'est hyper main ça fait
deux jours que je le fais c'est le feu
ouais mais c'est beaucoup mieux en fait
la révolution
incroyable en fait c'est ça c'est
pourquoi tu t'emmerdes à parler de
stratégie en fait parle de taille des
chiquitier quoi non mais oui mais c'est
vraiment c'est un très bon conseil
excellent
[Musique]
du coup j'ai mis en plus petit et je
sens que les pièces elles sont plus
proches quoi donc elles font moins mieux
elles sont plus en forme quoi
tu dois cliquer tu as moins de distance
avec ta souris dont on poignet il est
mieux enfin tout est mieux tu économise
complètement tes forces de tes pièces de
tes doigts de ta souris
après c'est surtout les pièces tu
imagines tu as un fou un hachis tu
allais prendre en C1 c'est loin même
pour les piles de ta souris quelque part
c'est bien c'est écologique bah c'est
écologique c'est un geste tu réduis le
voilà c'est très bien
c'est vrai que
en parlant de bacon on aurait pu penser
qu'il aurait voulu en échiquier plus
gros comme dans le chat c'est la taille
qui compte généralement
un truc attends j'arrive allez je vois
elle est partie avec un truc j'arrive
dans cette partie ça va être note les
deux joueurs qu'on sort bientôt moins
d'une minute
toujours un avantage pour les noirs
manœuvres et manoeuvre c'est bien après
on verra si la va convertir celle-ci il
a souvent raté dans ce match mais là
avoir pourquoi il est mieux parce que il
a sous de case noire qui peut se balader
à droite à gauche car j'ai trois en
attendant on va le refaire une case de 5
c'est le cavalier magnifique
shooter que j'ai pris tout à l'heure là
au gingembre pour la force quoi ouais
mais en fait elle avait fait tomber
et elle a récupéré elle a pris elle
partait avec quoi
il y a plus rien pour avoir dedans mais
elle a juste pris mais bon elle a pris
pour aller l'ouvrir un peu plus loin et
aller voir un petit peu ce qui se
passait quoi enfin un peu mordillette
elle m'a déjà volé des bouteilles
qu'elle a ouvert pour boire quoi
il est de nouveau gagnant hein c'est
bien ouais il est très bien on va voir
ce qui convertit cette fois
c'est pas fait juste tu es très bien tu
peux faire des G5 G4 qui vont partir tu
auras
ta magnifique
alors pour l'instant il y a DMC 5 c'est
cool mais parce qu'en fait j'ai gardé
mon kilo 5 et pas les gens contre un de
ces deux plot quoi
[Musique]
tu peux laisser ces pièces un peu
pourries il veut qu'il s'éclate
c'est quand même c'est quand même
quelque chose
c'est 4 attention
Maëva la rater c'est bien tu l'auras
écouter ici avant que ce soit terminé
femme ce sera l'image du match mais
écoute on sait jamais mais il faut j'ai
failli faut cliquer quoi garde ton
avantage
[Musique]
qui veut pas donner la case des 5 et il
empêche les C4 pour l'instant qui est
bien veut échanger une tour B8 reviens
on s'en bat les couilles
voilà
7 et puis on verra quoi attends il a
est-ce qu'il aurait pas défendu toutes
les cases
allez
au revoir
pousse ce pion
je sais pas il a 13 secondes
voilà
bien joué ça a priori il bouffe un truc
vous voir le roi transfertez tout ranger
et puis on verra bien
de toute façon
[Musique]
non mais tu es complètement nul il est
complètement nul mais bouge ton roi
allez
qu'est-ce que tu fous
il était devenu tout le match mais il a
perdu qu'une fois et il a su s'exerce
occasion donc bah écoute bon réaliste
mais sa qualifie attends je vais essayer
de regarder les règles du voilà et si
ils ont un horaire
on va voir
[Musique]
je sais pas
je sais pas Fab
bon c'est pas
[Musique]
interview
Rider
je comprends pas en fait pourquoi les
personnes qui écrivent sur ce truc
c'est sûr que ça Armageddon
mais attends faut qu'on aille voir sur
le live officiel nous aussi on a pas le
choix
parce que l'endroit où je devrais avoir
les infos il y a pas les infos donc
après Armageddon c'est Armageddon mais
ouais
un petit chrono à te mettre dans 5
minutes dans 10 minutes dans une
demi-heure dans une heure je sais pas
bah non
mais tu penses qu'ils vont faire une
pause encore assez énorme je sais j'ai
du mal à juger en fait
je sais pas mais ils sont capables de
tout en fait en plus on finit tellement
vite quoi
même maintenant là
ils ont fait durant 15 coups non
chacun la pendule sur 15 de départ ils
ont pas joué ça va tu as besoin de pause
par principe en fait pour le pour le
public en fait
le public se fait chier quoi
il est pas là pour faire des pauses il
est là pour voir des parties
je sais pas là c'est
farine le match je veux bien le laisser
une petite pause qui reprennent leur
esprit après un truc où tu as plus de
temps là tu fais qu'une minute à la fin
est un peu plus donc ça il y a pas de
problème mais
quand ça fait trois quarts d'heure tu as
fini ça va tu as fini ta pause quoi
bah je sais pas ça
tu me poses des questions j'ai pas les
réponses malheureusement
ce que je sais ce qu'ils analysent il y
a Gotham et narodisky qui analyse la
partie qu'on disait 12 secondes et bon
ben enfin c'est bon on s'en fout en fait
ils sont pas du tout comme nous en fait
c'est qu'il y a pas grand chose
évidemment c'était des mauvais coups
mais tu as plus le temps de bien jouer
donc
tu as pas grand chose à dire c'est comme
ça ça clique et puis Ben et là on clique
Sarine est plus fort que que c'est bien
c'est bien joué aux échecs mais cliquez
moins bien voilà ça a été ça en fait la
décision du match de clic au dessus du
jeu du jeu
je comprends pas trop
l'idée de la pause
en finale un truc qui pourrait durer
deux heures et demie trois heures ça
dure ça dure 5 heures quoi
une méta clip là c'est ça ouais on
essaie de regarder sur le live office
officiel on voit du riz est-ce que c'est
l'oeil parce que c'est un clip parce que
je pense c'était un clip parce que moi
j'ai l'image je les vois pas
on va rester on va pas faire de pause
parce qu'on sait pas donc on sait pas
dommage
des deux premières journées en fait là
ah bah oui
là on a une partie vraiment importante
bah là en fait ouais cette dernière
erreur c'était sympa parce qu'on a eu le
séviant Sarine avec
c'était chaud on avait guéri bon là bon
la partie a pas trop joué mais voilà
mais elle va jouer maintenant
donc là voilà
au final le match le plus large ça a été
saut
en six parties
le moins mérité entre guillemets c'est
c'est bien Sarine exactement
à priori c'est pas celui qui a fait les
meilleurs échecs qui a gagné
je vais verser le seul match dans ce cas
avoir un maximum ambulant ou un liaison
ambulant sur des tournois comme ça
tellement plus sympa à suivre
là c'est vrai que bon
c'est un peu ça le problème
savoir tu auras 200000 balles de plus ou
moins sur son compte en banque en gros
ça va qui va être un peu plus
multimillionnaire que l'autre à la fin
du tournoi c'est pas non plus
je pense que tu en penses toi
il y a plus grand monde qui me non non
j'ai aucun enfin
là dans les jours actuels c'est moins
mais après je sais pas tu vois j'aurais
eu cet âge là en 2000 peut-être que je
suis dire aussi personne enfin j'en sais
rien en fait je sais pas si c'est un
côté était jeune tu découvres tu étais
fan et
je sais pas il suffit de 200000 vraiment
ben pour te donner un ordre favoris Caro
il pèserait alors d'après le journal
Forbes ou je sais pas quoi 50 millions
de dollars et les joueurs ils doivent
gagner dans les 700 800 000 par an alors
pas forcément tous ceux qui sont là Raja
bof il est turbos blindés
ça c'est bien c'est peut-être séviant
Sarine ceux qui ont le plus besoin et
André Kin peut-être
il est content mais genre c'est pas
mais non c'est des joueurs habitués à
avoir à gagner pas mal en fait
donc attends nous on regarde le on
regarde en même temps live officiel pour
essayer de voir un peu les les temps on
va essayer de voir si on a un peu
quelque chose
je suis très heureux de dire
[Rires]
je te cache pas que j'étais quasi sûr
non mais bon
j'adore le dégoût de Fab quoi
non on se dit
quoi c'est pas
je sais pas pourquoi pas une demi-heure
en fait c'est
vraiment spécial la règle enfin je sais
pas
sérieux en fait dans ce que dans mon
dégoût parce que je veux dire même le
Championnat du Monde on dit [ __ ] 14
parties c'est long machin et quand ils
finissent leur 14 parties
mais quand tu es au foot tu as eu nul
auprès 90 minutes tu fais une
prolongation mais c'est 30 minutes tu
refais pas 90 minutes enfin même quand
il y a le but en or c'était que 30
minutes maxi et en fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est tout le temps
simple tennis tu finis ton sac tu as un
tie break mais c'est tout le temps ça
c'est pas c'est que sur une partie donc
il y a une logique non mais autant tu
fais deux Blitz 105 + 2 du coup bah oui
c'est un Armageddon à la fin enfin si tu
veux faire un truc comment tu fais deux
Blitz
mais là je suis d'accord je sais pas là
bon bref ok enfin c'est comme ça tant
pis mais je capte pas le délire en fait
bah c'est toujours plus long pour pour
mettre plus de pub pour je sais pas
je capte pas non plus le délire femme
mais le truc c'est que malheureusement
on en a pris l'habitude quoi je sais pas
comment dire mais
on sait que c'est comme ça mais du coup
voilà c'est sûr que c'est de plus en
plus dur de ce hyper toutes ces
compétitions
j'exagère mais de juste ah c'est pas mal
la technique gris il met des écouteurs
et le casque il le font tous j'ai vu OK
du coup on se donne à quoi sert le
casque en fait le casque ne doit pas
diffuser sur un truc anti-bruit je pense
aussi
c'est peut-être le sponsor aussi
on le voit pas bien
ouais mais il est enfin Razer il est un
peu partout quand même ah mais on le
voit très bien sur la chaise mais bon il
est sur le casque aussi hein tu le
devines hein ce serait beau qu'en fait
il se met des écouteurs dans les
oreilles et que
tu m'as bien compris si ce n'est pas que
des écouteurs
il vibre un peu l'écouteur
vibrant ouais
OK
[Musique]
il aurait parié 14 minutes 30
quoi
tu paries en fait
genre le mec a mis 15 minutes genre je
veux surtout pas les Noirs quoi en fait
mais je sais pas ça c'est le truc Raja
bof il veut pas les Noirs mais je sais
pas combien à midi oui quoi
non mais tu peux prendre 10 quoi tu es
bien
moi j'aurais mis 12 quoi
ça me saoule d'avoir les doigts ah mais
il joue
donc en fait
donc attends faut que je change
attends je change les camesab vas-y
change tout les blancs
c'est pas grave il y a des 5
il fait 6 d'abord ok ça va aussi on peut
toujours ok le 4 il y a toujours des 5
donc il a pris 13000 et 13 minutes ça me
paraît vraiment beaucoup oui
on va pas s'en servir la différence en
fait c'est juste gros avantage d'avoir
les marches et là maintenant des six et
E4 c'est 5 mais bizarre dans le choix
je pense que
vraiment mais en fait lui il voulait
vraiment les blancs
ok ben écoute pourquoi pas donc la règle
de l'Armageddon on la rappelle pour tout
le monde
des blancs doivent gagner
les blancs doivent gagner ils sont
obligés
quelqu'un qui écrit dans le chat
que l'on sait pas l'autre atlasie c'est
que
et non pas non mais en fait c'est
normalement les Noirs c'est quand même
un gros avantage puisque quand tu joues
en Armageddon normal on dit que 6
minutes contre 5 c'est mieux pour les
noirs
et en plus il y a pas de rajouter en
fait on est l'endroit de penser surtout
avec deux joueurs aussi solides que 12
minutes c'est vraiment beaucoup après
l'avantage d'avoir des blancs c'est que
tu sais ce que tu dois faire
nul quoi ouais mais des fois jouer pour
nul c'est pas à guérisse et faire
t'inquiète pas
mais là j'ai l'impression qu'en plus
avec les Noirs il sort enfin tu es très
heureux là
tu as une position complètement saine et
tu as juste besoin de nul en fait c'est
comme si c'était normal tu avais un peu
l'ouverture pour une bonne position
[Musique]
le centre il clique assez vite
d'ailleurs guérisse ou des coussins
naturels
c'est une option pas vraiment
bon après tu vas toujours prendre le
fouger 3 qui va revenir j'en sais rien
j'adore le coup de l'ordi cavalier H5
pour G5 et tout et tu es le fou
dans de bonnes conditions et tu trouves
le fouger cette cavalière H5 c'est pas
facile comme coup
c'était
prend les devants Fabien dans
il est ouais
mais c'est déjà la Turbo merde en fait
pour
les pas terrible alors là il se met en
C1 pour surprise avoir un vis-à-vis mais
pour commencer
ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]
et après peut-être trois H7 et F50 enfin
moi je suis chaud en fait
ouais bon c'est logique le pouvoir
reculer on a mon avis tu le manges quand
même ce four
serait dommage de le laisser partir non
après tu pourrais venir en F4 avec le
cavalier mais quand même un fou comme ça
ouvert
ça se prend non de le prendre alors tu
peux
faut pas se prendre la tête là dessus
non mais faut le prendre
bon après il réfléchit peut-être au coup
d'après parce que quand tu prends j'ai
trois tu sais qu'il va faire mais j'aime
bien prendre en fait dans le sens où si
tu le fais pas les blancs fraîches 80 en
tout cas lui il a gardé son foutu
donc je sais pas bizarre comme choix
mais bon ça peut s'entendre c'est pas
c'est pas dégueu pour les Noirs après il
peut se dire son cavalier va venir en F4
et qui sera supérieur au four
il peut avoir accès à des cases etc tu
as mauvais Fougères
en fait ce qu'il a joué
peut-être tu vas faire dame d'essai tu
vas voir des idées de sacrifices non non
ça suffit amplement
pour le moment en tout cas c'est une
partie qui se passe plutôt plutôt bien
pour Annie mais après il a aussi des
gars enfin dans ce match donc attention
Tour Eiffel tu peux peut-être un jour
replacer ton fond F1 en défense
ça se passe pas génial mais il va jouer
des coups pour pas perdre
et
passer le temps essayer de décider ça à
la fin
tu vas pas faire une victoire en
dominant son adversaire quoi c'est un
truc qui a l'arraché mais voilà c'est ce
qu'ils disent quoi résister jouer vite
et je veux son avantage au temps de
l'armée donc et ça ça stratégie de match
là il commence à tank un peu de temps et
en gros ouais
4 tu aurais fait ça mais à ce moment-là
tu as 2 30 contre une trente pas trop dû
le cliquer vite des coups t'en fous de
celui qui ait faim que trois tu sais pas
trop ce que tu fais quoi mais ça peut
marcher là avec autant de temps en face
j'ai l'impression que c'est tu dois
construire ta victoire ben tu peux pas
juste gagner en visant la pendule c'est
c'est le problème de cette Armageddon
avec beaucoup de temps c'est que ça
dénature un peu le principe même la
nature même de ouais ça dénature la
nature quoi parce que en fait la raison
du coup un de tes argument principal
avec les Blancs je vais pas flag
ouais c'est pour ça que tu es obligé de
gagner en fait c'est
ça te donne une arme supplémentaire que
là ici tu n'as tu l'as aussi mais tu
l'as évidemment beaucoup moins
ben on voit B4 en tout cas
ouais bon il veut
[Musique]
baisserait maintenant derrière le pion
et tapé un peu F7
après il se répand en obligation de
gagner on dirait bon il a une position
[Musique]
c'est ça le problème
en face de l'autre tour
éviter de perdre à 5 à un moment quand
il bouge le cavalier ou éviter un B5
mais déjà à 5 en soit c'est soupçonnant
parce que B5 c'était pas tellement de
menace enlever le cahier d'attaquer le
C4 donc tu pouvais faire ce que tu
voulais et là la série de couple plutôt
favorable au blanc attends je sais pas
s'ils sont mieux c'est pas le problème
là d'ailleurs on voit la jauge qui égale
mais mais on voit que ça s'améliorer
côté blanc tu as ton 2 contre un jour
c'est quatre la MP3 sont harmonieux ces
quatre est content de l'avoir fait juste
à trois en fait je passe un peu mon tour
je défends mon Punto
je vois un peu ce que tu fais tu as pas
trop de roi H7 j'ai [ __ ] en F7 bon je
suis là je suis bien quoi
je te rends le coup mais à trois c'est
quand même un coup de très utile enfin
je suis content de l'avoir
ça pour cliquer un truc pour te te
redonner le trait et après si tu fais
rien bah je verrai ce que je fais quoi
mais il le fait le feu
aussi
tu prends
tu reprends j'imagine peut-être
tu peux
et tout d'un coup tu vois tu es là non
je suis là et tu revois avec les
fouilles
j'aimerais bien ce plan je le cliquerai
assez rapidement personnellement
qui va rejoindre la niche au niveau
pendule ouais après à la rigueur si ça
finit en combat de en combat de clic de
toute façon tu gagnes ou tu perds c'est
tu vas cliquer quoi
mais pourquoi pas
il se place un peu par là
de bonne case mais la mauvaise pièce
ça a pas l'air d'être un cours non plus
là je j'aime pas trop mais
non non
je comprends bien il veut sur moi H7 et
puis faire F5
tu fais E4 t'ouvre ton fou j'essaie
on n'a pas du tout
[Musique]
parce que de base on aura envie quand
même
[Musique]
ouais c'est un peu cat en fait pas c'est
un peu dur hein
[Musique]
mais
je sais pas
c'était un gros coup de merde
bah je sais pas pourquoi il le fait
enfin faut suivre je sais pas par quoi
et cavalier c'est 5
ok vas-y
juste prendre B7
la question que je me posais en fait
je voulais repartir mais bon
en fait il est peut-être dans la merde
la S3 c'était bizarre
OK
on est pour ce 4 mais on B6 pourquoi pas
hein
c'est logique
elle est bien
bien placé
et qui a la position
après quand ça arrive ça va être une
belle opposition de style si c'est
Aniche qui se qualifie oui il peut se
faire arnaquer en fait il est nettement
plus fort mais le truc c'est que ça
arrive il va jouer que pour l'arnaque
bah faudra pas qu'il se fait trop mal au
dos
se faire arnaquer
la proie idéale
c'était pas le coup auquel je pensais
que tu allais passer 30 secondes 4
parce qu'il y a peut-être un problème
aussi si après tu as tellement
d'activités que
ça devrait aller mais peut-être
peut-être chercher le coup là dessus
en tout cas la Game a l'air entre les
mains du joueur néerlandais
qui domine mais le match contre contre
NiAl ça va vraiment être une opposition
de style intéressante Fab si il a lieu
de ça c'est pas encore fini
la position il a le temps maintenant il
a tout
mais bon on a vu on a vu d'autres depuis
hier
un moment ça peut tourner
en réalité voilà bah oui la partie là où
il a donné la qualité
en deux coups
du coup ce qu'il a calculé déjà en fait
tu récupères ton pion tu fais une finale
j'aime mieux le dame à cette crème mais
bon sois pleutre
après vu les conditions Claude éclairer
mais
c'est très éclairé là
mais ouais le choix de choix de prendre
les blancs pas payant
pour le moment
il a vraiment choisi quand tu donnes 14
minutes 30 c'est que tu veux avoir les
blancs
c'est pareil
il va réussir à prendre F7 mais
ça va pas aller bien loin
c'est rien
d'ailleurs je suis en train de me
demander sur fulprom en B4 faut prendre
F7 tu n'as pas roi fuite peut-être que
tu es avec toi
donc en fait il faut prendre même pas
[ __ ]
ok tu as juste une finale avec un pion
de mangue tu vas devoir gagner enfin
c'est ça va être complexe quand même
étonnant étonnant choix de Radjabov
après tu vois il aurait donné 12 minutes
30 il aurait quand même eu les blancs
j'aurais dit bon
il a là c'est vraiment le fait d'avoir
donné un
il a vu et juste il a toujours su de
toute façon il s'est dit de toute façon
il y a pas le choix
du joueur
qui n'aura pas démérités
que de toute façon tu as fait ton match
exactement
la dernière partie là c'est de l'avant
mais je pense pas qu'on a dit ça c'est
juste il a les blancs il essaye c'est
normal
et il aurait fait nul en essayant
c'était pas comme là ou si tu fais nul
c'est fini
là il a il a plu il reste le mystique
à part ça
va être tout reprendre non quand même
pas
ah mais il y a F3 j'ai 3 ans
et oui
qui gagne de belles manières
ouais ouais il a maîtrise de
l'Armageddon de fondant en fait il a
pris l'avantage dans l'ouverture il a
jamais il a pas lâché il a jamais lâché
vraiment pas mon avis sur Stari non de
ce type faut que les Noirs a peut-être
moins de 10 minutes pour que ça soit un
peu un peu serré sinon normalement c'est
c'est un truc pour être un peu fun quoi
là c'était pas fun non
je préfère le fait de faire de Beat 105
+ 2 après faire un armaged enfin après
ça prend autant de temps que ça sauf que
c'est dix fois plus marrant et je trouve
plus juste aussi en réalité
après ouais est-ce que ça va contrôler
les plugs Fab
on verra en tout cas on se retrouve
c'est pas le nôtre pas encore à tout
moment il y a Vlad qui va se présenter
qui va devenir arbitre bah oui c'est une
nouvelle carrière qui se présente à lui
donc on se retrouve à demain Fab pour
pour les matchs qui opposent qui
opposent qui opposeront Nakamura
principal j'imagine mais on se voit
quand même guéri et Niels
assez sympa après ouais on peut aller
avoir le match nakasso qui peut qui peut
être intéressant ou qui peut être
complètement pourri enfin c'est je sais
pas comment dire bah c'est on sait pas
sur le papier pourquoi pas mais
évidemment ça peut se passer
ce soir
mais Sarine guéri dans tous les cas ce
sera marrant oui parce que c'est
vraiment deux joueurs opposés quoi
complètement en position de style en
perspective
merci à toi Fab moi je vais aller faire
quelques petits Blitz et on se retrouve
on se retrouve quand d'ailleurs
ça marche voilà c'est ça